[Music]
real quick
[Music]
all right testing testing realm let me
know if you can hear us
talk to me real quick sorry about that
y'all technical difficulties round two
we back down the taco what's up can you
hear me
can you hear me anyone mike jack all
right cool i'm talking to the chat fuzzy
i think you're talking to that i'm
talking to them
[Music]
thank you thank you all right so what we
got as long as you can see that feedback
on obs that they should definitely
all right
we're back at the main screen
let us know again see desktop audio
again there you go i mean i know what to
do though i know what to do try for
these no i see i see it absolutely good
let me ram talk to the people i mean
attic talk to the people okay
hello hello hello all right this is sony
out here censoring the lords wow
all right so everybody can hear
everybody but it's not us yeah shout out
to ksi yeah about obs too it lost its
mind
no doubt i always do it manually every
podcast yeah and i usually check but
that's all me that's all i mean so we
are back give me a second
we'll get things when you guys get a
chance retweet that podcast tweet yeah
if you can yeah some people think we
canceled today's show yeah
all right it's like there was not a lot
of struggle back at the moment any kind
of technical issues well that's it see
you next time he left us all right
everyone's good to go
somebody said
how you do me like that how you doing me
like that stitch don't be judging my
financial situation
all right we ready
hear you hear ye again and we are live i
think welcome to the ireland podcast llc
and also live on launchinggaming.net
episode number 244 it's another glory
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's date i'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
call of duty and popular activision
games on playstation
platinum games warning scale bound ps5
voice commands and nintendo direct to
discuss so we're going to get right into
it shout out the hard fine with the 2
super chat oh good call don't let it let
it happen again thank
you let it happen again thank you sir
for chastising again hugs hosting
abilities is being jeopardized damn
all right let's get to it i want to
introduce lord his unique skill set of
cool videography ocular inspection and
educational humor is an absolute treat
for gamers to focus in on
introducing the current practice
practicing optometrist plus creator and
host of the dr i guy youtube channel
the lord that keeps our eyes healthy and
vision clear
who's also been known to shake them hips
and jab out at his old eye practice he's
laughing
i caught that video live from idaho and
making his debut into the realm of the
lord
my man lord dr neil guyman aka dr i guy
how are you doing again sir
i am doing great i'm actually secretly
glad the whole audio thing happened
because that then i got the chance to
hear that awesome influence again
how does it feel yeah you heard it twice
and some lords liked it once
absolutely what you do man what you've
been up to and what games have you been
playing man
yeah again thanks for having me so this
this is great so uh yeah games i
like what i was saying before when
nobody could hear me
i am i am busy you know between
you know in my my practice you know work
full time there and then and then the
youtube channel so i spent a lot of time
there obviously so i'm i'm fitting games
in between the crevices here so i mean
obviously some people know me from like
a lot of the videos about you know the
oculus quests
yeah so so i've been playing a lot of
that i think the most recent games i've
been playing or the recent game in there
has been uh damio oh
you want to stay tuned to the lords in
about a couple of weeks trust me
oh okay trust me on if you're a demio
fan stay tuned to iop in about a week or
two
okay
well that's a dangerous game i played it
one night on friday with my with my
friends i had to be to work uh saturday
bad bad decision i was up until like
four in the morning
it's dangerous dangerous game but yeah
so
uh-huh
yesterday we were playing it my
girlfriend came home at midnight and i
was like okay we got like 40 50 minutes
before she gets home she was home for
like an hour before we finished that
match like
yeah it's crazy it could cause problems
out there real quick a lot of chat is
asking who is this guy this is doctor i
got let me put a channel in there
like who is he
that's who he is
he's a sony rep
he's like no don't say that no yeah you
familiar eyes to him you're loading what
you do man we gotta we got a lot to talk
about we're gonna get you somebody don't
want it to the eye
uh ridiculous
to the eye so you'll nail your eyes
you're ridiculous anyway moving on
because we're late and you already know
we got the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with definitely
time-sensitive intros now my co-host
with the co-host
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his old
world and the how of the young wolf my
man lord addict how we doing sir i'm
doing pretty good i'm gonna keep this
short uh i actually played sifu and uh
it's actually one of the best games in
the playstation right now so
you know that's as far as i'm willing to
go on that i'll be reviewing it probably
the next week
because i'm on the last boss and he
keeps he he's he's definitely
annoying me but uh yeah that that's my
intro no i appreciate you man and of
course we have our most technical gaming
lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bank mommy lord sovereign how
we doing sir i'm good doing very good uh
i have been uh chipping away again at
halo infinite i'm almost at the end okay
yeah you know how i guess yeah
uh sifu as well i'm in the third area
now um i love that game don't take it
as a camera in 24 minutes wow yeah i
mean it is that kind of game when you
when you really look for 15.99 on pc and
wow playstation dudes paying 40 bucks
here we go 40 bucks it's that is it it's
definitely worth 40 times we have
guessed that we ain't got time to be
done
and then on the switch really quickly
big shout out to uh to our friend jonah
wallerstein yeah and his the launch of
his game that we've followed for many
years now um
kung fu people
everywhere so shout out to him i've been
playing that it is hilarious fun it is
absolutely amazing um and then uh give a
big give a look to uh our review over on
logicgaming.net by lord daniel amoroso
as well as a q a with jonah over at
logicgaming.net so please check that out
i'll put those links in the chat yeah
please check that out no doubt and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that freedom experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
oh
doing better than danny jacobs uh shout
out to somebody that's not inspired to
fight and keep fighting bums what
happened you lose the one
well it is what it is um
not you
guys it's it's certain guys that's
running around in the in the realm
and they they're acting a little bit
strange i have to explain to you guys
exactly how you lose knees
all right because
your parents please
[Music]
the caretakers
and the dictators on how
you can lose knees yeah spend any
segment correct the knees is your word
is your bond
like back in the iron ages
you know you had if you had to bend the
knee that meant a lot
so that's your word the only way that
you can bend the knee or lose your knees
is you actually make a direct bet with
somebody and that person acknowledges
your direct bet and takes that challenge
factual you cannot go to sleep and wake
up and sony purchase something and you
lose knees
that's not how it goes that's how the
rules of engagement is okay please
please stop now just just just a little
real quick man talk yeah um
i gotta let you guys know something
because being that i'm the leader of the
fraud police
there's a lot of frauds out here doing a
lot of fraudulent stuff and
you guys are growing up at a different
time you don't have a big home you don't
have a probably a pops around an uncle
around someone to look up to to tell you
how to move in these streets how to be a
solid individual
now let me tell you something a real
solid individual does not need a
co-defendant in anything you don't need
to hashtag
people tactically
and they don't need to talk on another
man to build they self up
now
let me explain what i mean
when you're not credible what you do is
you take a credible individual
and you place them next to you
to make you look credible
all right
so
i want you to
look at these individuals
and if you remove the credible person
away from their programming because
these dudes take six seven hours to edit
video put video up and try to associate
their self with a credible individual
you remove the credible individual from
said video and what do you have
a non-credible individual
and looking for individuals to hold
these coattails so brother please go
disappear don't use me because i will
never use you because you're not
credible oh god moving on what you've
been playing sir
only yes you think a game pass yes so i
played like the um
they released
uh pillars of eternity
and what was this one game that i love
so much skull okay that little
that little skull dude like he's a
little bone guy he's absolutely the
cutest
and he gets to chuck his head right it's
a roguelike
and he gets to chuck his head and
teleport to his body which i find
absolutely amazing
so i'm throwing my little head all over
the place and i'm like teleporting to my
body and also um
what is this the the last kids on earth
okay it's pretty cool it reminds me of
the adams family like updated version of
the adams family with uh like better
controls and stuff like that better
visuals so i'm actually having fun with
that do not
play
crossfire
[Music]
even i tried i didn't know okay is the
single player locked do you have to
purchase the single way to buy the
singles
that whole thing is in the bushes it's
i don't know how you know why you guys
downloaded that
i didn't i played it
i had to see it for myself yeah and and
i realized maddie was right shout out to
the best shout out to mr maddie plays no
doubt yeah that's it and
and i'm done
please guys thank you stay away from
those non-credible individuals thank you
for the public service announcement we
appreciate that and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spread that ronin around
the iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to defining duke had mr maddie plays
talking about again a lot of the
activision that our stuff also um kind
of had a fun little sports segment
segment about what teams we like why we
like the teams we like also check out
that uh last media patreon for that
defining duke
ultimate where uh lord king did the
crossover we had uh he made his uh
defining duke ultimate debut had an xbox
one retrospective absolutely fire we
took it back
yeah i right when we watched that
episode it was that was a classic that
was a cloud we we went through the
moments the highs the the lows
you know what i'm saying and a lot of
other things so yeah check that out also
last word when he bought this time got
travis i can't be alert but we had late
but we had a hilarious episode shoot out
to them we had a talk about witch queen
void 3.0 and the legendary campaign for
me it's been sifu destiny grind been
getting back into it getting my
materials up and of course like doctor i
got mentioned that demio me addict shout
out to jansen shout out to sin four
hours went back was it the black
sarcophagus two levels hilarious we had
the bard we had the guardian we were
doing our little thing it was good it
was good so check that out but uh now
that we got into what the lord actually
before we do that um sorry we want to
pay the bills um real quick if we got
any do we missed it
yeah we got a couple yeah let's get
those crazy uh so we have first we got
mama boucher two dollars
super chat foosball it's the devil
shout out to the water boy
let's put the crust to the chat for
chocolate mango oh welcome to the realm
sir hold on hold on hold on let me
salute him um
salute to you i did not know video game
amateur site was run by him he did a
tremendous kind of uh thing on me and
and iron laws and what we do
and you know bro you had the ta come to
my eye thank you for the recognition
through a black history month it really
meant a lot to me i want to salute you i
didn't i had to because i dm the account
they're not knowing who it was just to
thank them he's like yo this chocolate
come on go i'm like
i know what you are you're in the chat
yo salute to you brother you made my day
was a rough week to see that and to get
the appreciation for the community
during this month you have no idea what
that means thank you brother continue
yourself fantastic and we got flame five
dollar super chat let's face it no one
will shut up about scale bound until one
week after it's officially released
because no one really cared for it have
a good show
that we have cedric h member for 20
months thank you sir um with nothing
else to say and we've got doomy
a member for 15 months the best part of
my sunday let's get it hit that like
button
and we have boonty remember
you don't know
enough respect lords
[Laughter]
let's go
let me get hard to find like cox say oh
good cog just to let it happen again and
we have
daryl back with the five dollar super
chat shout out to the lords and lord
cognito that oculus quest 2 is fire or
hell the iop salute thank you sir shout
out to you for yeah i guess he's driving
cross cross-country or something like
that
hollywood rules five dollar super chat i
thought my sunday was all messed up but
glad the four horsemen are riding on a
snowy super bowl sunday yes adam king
hashtag y'all only getting war zone 2 oh
my god we'll get to that later
then we got haruki chinese five dollars
we checked with a lot of hashtags
hashtags playstation is a monopoly iop
is in the bushes hashtag playstation are
hypocrites on violence oh my god
we have the fraud alert then we have
hashtag ps tries to cancel iop
oh that's what happened
thank you and then we have oh and
hashtag put eldon ringing game
pass ridiculous
then we got a big shout out to the homie
big cloud gaming
chat welcome to lord bronze big cloud
gaming we're gonna roll back for a
minute we got cmad five dollar super
chat all we've heard from microsoft in
statements from phil and brad is we
desire
to make available is game pass the price
for non-microsoft platforms
probably but we'll see like i said
cloud is not there yet then we got lord
roughness five pound super chat salute
my iron lord shout out to the messy
lords destiny and cod staying multi-plat
i don't care put elden ring on game pass
wow but they really want that really
whatever
we're caught up all right cool and real
quick for the merch want to shout out
angry hippie he got that classic t that
phil
dominus maximus shirt salute to him and
then um let's see a lot of yeah a couple
of anonymouses about ilp shirts and then
donald taco uh says real quickly saw
that we missed his super chat in last
stream so yeah
yeah let us know i missed my super chat
in the last stream we came back on and
read it yeah okay so if not you know
donald trump is just at me or yeah just
just pop throw it in here again if you
can alright cool we all caught up
yeah all right we have a patient guest
so now
that we've gotten to where all the lords
have been playing i want to focus back
on lord i got this video game system
history his journey as an optometrist
and of course what led him to create the
outstanding doctor i got youtube channel
so lord i got let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
okay we're going back we're going back i
was born in 1983 so i was born i was
born a month after the nintendo system
came out
okay so obviously i started with that i
think a lot of people did you know
classical mario yeah um and then just
you know upgrade it from there and
intend super nintendo nintendo 64.
um had a playstation in there and then
went to xbox xbox 360 xbox one you know
so that's that's kind of my route and
then you know a lot of pc gaming there
for
but sure that's so um
i you know a lot of fond memories like
everybody does of having like friends
over playing golden eye you know
you know you know classic memories and
then it you know morphs into online
gaming with the
halo and call of duty and
you know so i followed that that general
trend that i think a lot of people did
you know no doubt just out of curiosity
uh have you heard the rumors i don't
know if you keep up with stuff like that
but apparently microsoft's like in like
good talks right now with nintendo to
bring goldeneye rematch master back yeah
what no i have not heard of that yes oh
no apparently it's like a really good
chance that it's happening no way yeah
yeah so see a lot of those games i i see
like you said the hey like you said the
golden eyes you had kind of like
nintendo now i guess like for you said
you kind of obviously you're born around
the nintendo but like what were your
kind of like
one your first console that you remember
for yourself like really attaching
yourself to was it the super nintendo
did you stay there or like what was the
first like
game that you really kind of attached to
and then from a console standpoint you
really attached to
yeah so i have memories actually with
the original nintendo
um
you know young but uh
but definitely like super nintendo was
probably when i uh i would say
started playing the most getting really
into it
oh yeah so i remember doing mike tyson's
punch
and nintendo yeah yeah
i have memories of that and then uh and
then
just punch out on the super nintendo
um
those i mean those are like strong
memories and then nintendo 64. um
yeah so i attached to the nintendo
pretty fast but but but then i just you
know i kind of merged over an xbox when
that came came on
so okay switched right over now question
as far as the friends in in the area and
stuff like that where um anybody had
cause a couple of sega kids here in the
panel so anyone had a say were you
familiar or was like yeah
didn't know anyone we were just nintendo
all day
no no so i i i didn't have a sega but i
had friends that i'd go to the cigar
what was the what was the oh man oh god
i'm gonna sound really stupid because
there's a sega um genesis and they have
like the huge attachment and play the
cds oh yeah there we go
what was that sega cd yeah yeah yeah i
don't remember that's what that is
yeah that's it
yeah i remember my my friend their
family had that and i remember going
over their house and they're like
putting a cd in there and i just
remember i'm like oh my gosh this is
crazy i live in the future
yeah this is like this is awe you know i
can't believe this is real and then you
know i look back at it and i'm like wow
that's that's bad but you know it sucks
so bad but when we saw actual full
motion video on the team
it was like oh we're in the future
yeah it's like oh girl yes great yes
definitely definitely at home like i
said the cd era stuff like that so that
you go again you stay pretty much the
nintendo ecosystem you go to 64 right at
one point yep okay any standouts there
and also in the super nintendo era i
just wanted any other standouts during
those two nintendo eras
you know i stayed pretty generic i mean
there was the the mario karts and the
marios and the um zelda you know i
played a lot of zelda
and then uh he had nintendo 64 you know
with that the golden eye and
you know mario's and all that so that i
mean that those are my fondest memories
i mean i obviously played a bunch of
games but right those are the memories i
had no doubt really good memories yeah
without no doubt so continue that and
then obviously just stuck with it i'm
gonna assume you know i say xbox you
mentioned you had the ogx box did you
have the 360 i had the og
oh you got the big block the big with
the big okay
that was that the the one for you like
what made you kind of get going to the
ecosystem
yeah so gaming kind of morphed into um
you know like with halo and
well on goldeneye and everything is
pretty much like a way that you can get
together with friends but they want it
you know as it um morphed into
you know online game play that was like
the way that you can actually keep in
contact with friends i mean when i went
to you know college and then optometry
school i mean that was the way i kept in
touch with my brother
my brother-in-law my friends and so it
not only became just like gaming it
became
you know that's where i had the social
aspect that's like it almost became a
therapy for me you know from with
optometry school i mean that was my that
was my release yeah no good good
transition because um obviously i want
to talk i know a little bit behind so i
don't want to get as much in with you
but yeah you know the thing is now we
transition because now like what most
people know for you are in real life
like you're a real life eye doctor real
life optometrist so like
how did that journey start and then like
when you always passionate about
becoming an eye doctor
so
not always it was pretty much in college
i actually uh actually started off as
gonna be i was gonna be a computer
programmer
um
so that's what i initially started off
as but then i had
um
but i couldn't see so i went to the eye
doctor
so i went to the eye doctor and uh
actually became really good friends with
him actually did a residency there and
shattered with them and so that's that's
that's actually what got me into the
field and then
and so then that's what made me kind of
pursue that career as a as an eye doctor
nice yeah nice
and then um gotta bring it in now to uh
you know you do you do you do the eye
doctor thing
to um what you call to content creation
so
yeah you're just you know great eye
doctor you gotta practice you're doing
your thing
what in the hell made you say you know
what i'm gonna make a youtube channel
i'm gonna get into the crazy world of
youtube like how did that happen
yeah so
i uh i i've actually always liked doing
videos in fact i made videos when i was
in optometry school about optometry
um but you know really really when it
came down to the pandemic um
and you know we had our office closed
down for a little while and
and so you know obviously you start like
searching ways of like where you can
like better educate you know my own
patients or answer questions that people
had and you know so obviously you kind
of you know look online and then i
started doing video creation i'm like
wow if i can just make some videos
answering specific questions that people
have like my patients then i could play
it in our offices i could send it to
patients and then that that's how it all
kind of started right there nice nice
yeah man
really cool and we were talking you know
offline you know about how a lot of us
found you you know kind of thing so it's
really cool so i want to do on really
quickly like uh
some comprehensive i quit quite care
kind of q and a with the
doctor oh god we got to take advantage
while we have him so um real quick this
one's for me i'll open up the q a
everybody's getting consultations yeah
we're gonna get a free copy
we're gonna promote the practice brother
so here's the things here's the thing so
like for me you know obviously i do the
whole gaming glasses so i gotta ask for
a lot of people to ask this question and
you know
i know you have some videos and stuff
like that like
gaming glasses
orange tits gimmick or no
okay ooh good question this is a good
question okay so the
it's uh yes it's a gimmick and no it's
not a gimmick
[Laughter]
and the reason the reason why i say that
is because
blue light blue light is even
i mean crazily debated even in the eye
doctor world i mean if you go to um
the facebook with all the eye doctors i
mean they'll even argue about how well
blue light glasses work is blue light
actually dangerous is it causing all
these problems and they've studied it
like crazy if blue light is actually
causing damage to the eyes
they they they're um there's that the
jury's still ought to out on that one
there still needs to be a lot of
research that needs to be done on that
it's actually gonna like hurt the the
retina you know damage the eyes
the big one is if it's actually causing
digital eye strain right
and that's the one that's completely
mixed you'll get some studies that will
show oh yeah it absolutely causes
digital eye strain and then some studies
will show like no doesn't do anything um
blue light isn't contributing at all and
so that's where the struggle comes from
is because you'll have some studies that
say like yeah you need blue light
glasses and some that are saying
um they're not and the most recent
studies have come out is saying that
it's not causing digital eye strain and
so yeah so that's the most recent
studies now what is absolutely true
though is it definitely messes with
melatonin production which which affects
your sleep uh and so that's what talk
about my favorite word would you talk
about circadian rhythm
circadian rhythm
yeah talk to that exactly yeah so we do
know that the the the gaming glasses
that are that we do know are actually
beneficial are the ones that probably
have like a yellow tint orange tint red
tint yeah because it's black yeah yeah
just like you just like
exactly
i want the bag what's up about it yeah
exactly
continue i'm super shocked those are the
ones yeah those things
yeah
so those are the ones that are actually
blocking the certain
wavelengths of blue light that's coming
from our screens and so those ones are
actually doing something the clear ones
may be helping with digital eye strain
it does help some people some people say
it so it's just a placebo which possibly
it is but but a lot of people say hey
yeah it actually helps so it's it's
tricky it's it's it's tough it's still a
lot more study here it's still a lot
more studying oh yeah and i respect that
you just said that let's get kid cause
he got his hand up before we opened up
okay thank you so much
yeah yeah
all right so i got into a car accident
um
whoa okay and this is good december
of uh
2021. and um
you know i i didn't think anything of i
hit my head at the back of the you know
the headrests yeah right didn't think
anything of it you know the police asked
you are you dizzy did you black out i'm
like uh if i blacked out i wouldn't know
like
did you find me sleep or something
why are you asking me that's a great
question right so
it's like um a week goes by and i really
don't pay it don't mind but i'm laying
on my side right and i'm looking at tv
i fall asleep on my other side i turn
over on my other side and i'm on my left
side and i go to sleep and i wake up and
i have a picture of my dog
um that's above the bed so i open my
eyes and my eyes is a little blurry and
i notice the picture is off center and
i'm like what the hell i'm looking
and i'm like why isn't my eyes adjusting
properly
right i go to the doctor and they said i
have a full a fourth nerve
palsy yeah in my right eye as a direct
result of the car accident
and you know they said it takes either
six months to a year to clear or they
have to give you a glass you know
glasses with a prism in them yep
the doctor wanted to be funny she was
like well you could wear a patch like
nick fury yo
yo you make a good look fury
no no that's just
a jacket right now we
kevin feige i got the replacement baby
let's go
please mute him please
continue so um and and as a eye doctor
my question to you is um do you do you
get that often with like head trauma
fault nerve palsy and stuff like that uh
and could you explain to everyone
exactly what is the process when you get
a fourth nerve palsy
yeah so
so forced nerve palsy so that innervates
one specific muscle in the eye the
superior oblique of the eye and so
that's and so that's probably why if you
had it in one eye that one eye was
probably not pointing the same direction
as your other eye and so is that why
you're is probably off off centered and
tilted a little bit yeah yeah so
um yeah that's very unique and
um
yeah they said yeah you could you could
wear prism which would shift the vision
down that so do you have double vision
usually regularly it's okay it's only
when i tilt to the extremely to the left
and it has gotten better over a period
of time uh you know she said it will get
better
as it heals because they don't want to
do surgery like after i i saw the video
for surgery i was like hell no
yeah oh yeah
yeah
it's not uh
uh an exact science and you can make it
actually worse
uh you know type of things though
yeah we have to deal with that a lot
like with the concussions in general did
you have a concussion from it it's
possible i see again right yeah
yeah when it was asking me to question
you know usually the thing that goes
with concussion is either uh
dizziness or uh nausea right and i
didn't have any nausea
slight dizziness and i and i realized
that i'd hit my head backwards because
he hit me from behind post yeah um
so
that's his car was destroyed
because i drive a truck and he had like
this little thing um
but i realized after and some a lot of
times you know you're just so happy that
you're not you don't have a broken bone
true true or you don't you know have
something else and you don't realize
that these things these little peepers
in your eye your head these eyeballs are
very very delicate and something very
minor and it wasn't a gigantic car
accident but it was enough that it
shifted
my vision
and i wouldn't have noticed if i didn't
lay on my left side that day to go
normally i lay on my right side
yeah
yeah wow that's yeah that's a that's a
crazy story and really the eyes are
super delicate there'll be some people
that will won't notice that for a while
you know like they'll have some kind of
trauma or something happen to their eye
and then like they'll be like a month or
two later and they're like i for some
reason i'm getting double vision like
kind of what you said if they like tilt
their head a certain way
or sometimes if they're laying on their
side they'll they'll have double vision
just because that either the nerve or
the muscle kind of got affected from the
trauma and you know mess it up but but
yeah you're right you're luckily um it
will slowly heal and come back and and
get better
yeah we need we need to kick into yeah
that's what they say so a lot of dudes
will probably say date david is
cock-eyed no i'm not
we're not gonna do that we're not gonna
do that dude i gotta [ __ ] all right
moving on oh let's get
you got your hand up so you got a q a
what's up man what you got for doctor
guy i got oh cool yeah yeah
oh i don't hear him he's muted right
here he's muted
he's like he did it like me when i muted
the whole podcast
the crazy thing i don't have a question
but like the crazy thing about your eyes
is your eyes are so like subconsciously
important to your body that
your body just naturally defends them if
they're like because that's why like a
lot of the times when like something's
about to hit you you always try to
protect your head and you don't even
think about it like you naturally just
do it to protect your eyes from from
damage
yeah i mean if you i mean this is this
is where it gets crazy so so 50 to 60
percent of our brain is involved with
processing vision
so so that's a crazy amount of brain
power that's involved in vision i mean
not necessarily just sight but
processing what's coming in and reacting
to it and everything i mean that's 50 to
56 of your brain is involved with this
little inch globe organ
in your body in fact there there are
more neurons coming from your uh your
eye hooking up your brain than any other
organ combined that's like heart lungs
you know anything
is all from the eyes it's it's crazy
sorry i'll stop talking no no no we're
not right we're learning
awesome at least 80 of us video game
players wear glasses
we're going to get to
yeah yeah actually like i was saying uh
offline before we came on um so the way
i i found uh dr eight was that as soon
as i got my my oculus quit my meta quest
too
um i
yeah so i was um please don't call it a
quest too moving on moving on
so um
i
i just i i noticed that i was just
constantly getting blurry constantly and
it happened with the with the first with
the original quest um that i had as well
i'm like i can't last more than 20
minutes or so without without it it's
going blurry and it just i just can't do
it and i wear contact lenses so um and
because i'm super blind like i i think
one time i didn't wear my contacts on
this show when i wore my coke bottle
glasses and the chat the chat let me
know oh they've roasted the crazy part
the crazy part solve is like i have that
exact same issue and like i for the
longest time i didn't realize there's a
strap at the top and like when i
strapped that to make sure it stayed on
my eyes in a specific way i i was blurry
but once you like it it's all about like
the the straps on the oculus is designed
to keep your eyes in front of the lens
the way it should be the way it should
be right the way it should be but
whatever all the movement if you're
playing beat saber or something like
that it's gonna move around and jingle
around so for me um so i always try to
just have my contacts in
while doing that because my glasses it
just feels like it's just an extra my
glasses are heavy or whatever so i have
my contacts on right now and these on my
reading glasses over my contacts that's
how blind i am so um
so
one of the first videos i saw from you
was obviously the one about the blurry
eyes and why that happens but the second
one that was there was really
informative for me and i still haven't
gone that route to purchase but the the
uh the prescription lenses that cover up
they go over the uh the oculus lenses so
uh can you because you had some like
reviews and whatnot so what has your
experience been that in that regard with
those prescription lenses because i
think that to me feels like the perfect
sort of solution to somebody who doesn't
want to strap the headset on over their
glasses
yeah so and that's usually what i tell
people is uh so um
so glasses in fact here let me say this
because a lot of a lot of people still
ask me this is uh you know do i if i'm
nearsighted so meaning if their vision
is naturally you know right here then
they still have to wear glasses when
they play vr and and so what kind of
like trips them up is because they think
the headset's right here but the lenses
are actually
projecting the image uh 143 meters out
it's about four feet so if you need
glasses to wear four feet or further
then you're gonna wanna wear glasses in
in vr especially with oculus quest so
yeah so
um glasses but it's yeah it's just
another step another thing to wear in
the quest it's and it's it can be
uncomfortable it could be pinching it
you risk scratching the lenses and so
and so then the answers there either
wear contacts which not everybody does
wear contacts or
you can get the prescription lens
inserts um which are awesome and i've
had
i've had the opportunity to um review
four
companies that do it
and and everyone that i've reviewed the
prescription that they made was like
exactly right was perfect and so that
that's an excellent option i think a lot
of people should look into
if if they're just don't want to wear
glasses in vr yes big time big time glad
you said a good treasure because um you
know obviously with me vr and it's the
same thing like as a glasses guy i'm
just going to be brutally honest and i
said this to you all stream like i feel
it's really rough on glasses guys
because one the positioning of the
headset and then i was positioned wrong
and i had like this part like really
pressing down onto my nose bridge then
it was just the blurriness and then just
you know taking it off putting it back
on taking it off but like it was just an
uncomfortable situation so again came
across dr i got videos he had like all
these prescription lenses and i'm like
all right and then one of them which is
really cool i think i ended up going
with the the real optics one but
what was cool is you you broke down how
great all of them were right and then
but i like the fact that it was one that
just were magnetic and they just little
snapped on to the little you know saying
to the thing and i learned about my pid
the the eye distance everything with
that and since then
i've been loving it without glass like
i've been like that is the best that
it's so clear it's more clarity so yeah
salute to you for that and um real
quickly um i know you talk about with vr
and stuff like that there are questions
sometimes with with kids and long-term
effects of vr like you know any studies
out right now anything or is it still
ongoing like how's that data with with
kids in vr and just the long-term
effects of playing games of vr
yeah so i actually did a video about
that and it was actually kind of a risky
video as an eye doctor to make because
there really is not a lot of research
done i mean there is some but as far as
like long-term effects we don't know so
we're kind of taking a lot of the
information we know from like looking at
our screens and ipads and we're kind of
just
we're automatically assuming that that
would apply to vr which it probably can
but um so i was kind of risky that i did
that video because there's a lot of that
information that might change
but i kind of mentioned that in the
video but um
so i kind of so i kind of say tell
people i'm um you do want to follow the
guidelines that they say like 13 and
older with like the oculus quest um so i
do mention that but
basically if you are going to let your
kids play i mean so now that i said that
i have a i have an eight-year-old and
you let him play you know so
and and but we you just want to be
careful like i usually kind of harp on
the 20 20 20 rules
yeah yeah every 20 minutes you try and
make them take at least a 20-second
break looking 20 feet away so pretty
much just like gives your eyes a chance
to you know breathe blink you know look
away um and that will kind of just like
reset the eyes a little bit
and so so i usually tell people that if
you if you're you're staying to that i
mean that's going to improve your
chances i mean significantly of anything
bad happening in the future so what
about like drops or anything like should
they be like you know like as far as to
keep the eyes because let's be honest
you are staring right for a long period
of time and it kind of transfixed so is
it a good like rule of thumb maybe
before you start a long play session
before we do our demo should i be like
grabbing the little the little drop you
know and say like
you're gonna need a whole bottle for
that game
yeah you'll be on there for a long time
but i'm actually glad you brought that
up because that's that's a big one so a
lot of people actually kind of laugh at
me for saying like you need to remember
to blink when you're playing vr because
you are you are really staring and so
the surface of your eye dries out
but the one potential long-term effect
that you could have there is your your
oil glands will actually atrophy because
the blinking mechanism is what actually
um creates the oil yeah out of your oil
glands if you don't blink you don't
secrete oil and then those my bowling
it's like you if you don't use your arm
muscle yeah hulk over here you know his
arm muscle it'll go down and like become
just nothing nubs
um so it's it's it's big and that could
be a big one a long-term effect one with
kids but again i mean
there's not really big studies yeah yeah
yeah exactly it's tricky no i got you i
just looked at that i got to remember
blink just play when i'm playing these
music gotta gotta get the bling got the
screen to get the glands going all right
um i did want to ask about um
basically from a basic gamer console
gamer you know the hardcore guy right so
it's like you know i added forgive me
this is just this for you
like the guy who you know extremely long
gameplay sessions
dark i'm blind
[Laughter]
we gonna do our therapy session with my
man you know what i'm saying so it's
like you know you know extremely long
sessions sometimes really low lit rooms
on a computer screen
attic fix your face or you know like the
old you know you're doing that i
actually don't have a low lit room like
that's the time i have my light on back
in the day though back there well um
you know or the guy like myself i'm
guilty you know oled television low
light room staring hours game play
session like
what can we do what can that guy do that
gamer do to protect themselves as much
as possible don't buy tcl right
yo don't you do that
[Laughter]
one of the arguments my mom used to use
against me so i don't know if i told you
this like
she used to try to get oh yeah
you're gonna go blind like that gaming
it's evil and that's what you can watch
tv for 10 hours would you watch tv
that we want you to do but that gaming
like what what can we do to get them off
us well it does use like fast twitch
motions in your eyes like if you're
playing a very fast twitch game my wife
saw me playing doom
she said that's why you got that posing
yeah that's what that's what they do
she's like see what i have to get
posey
because you're playing this damn doom
and it's too damn fast
you gotta help us this is what the
matriarchs of the realm they try to shut
us down as young kids they try to stop
the fun you gotta give me some
scientific reasons i can fight back yeah
so okay so okay here's what you can use
to fight back um
so so you say hey you know um why don't
you just play with me
okay that's that sounds like that's so
no really the
eyes um
they're resilient i know i kind of harp
on the 2020 rule and you know taking
breaks and your oil glands
but really like if you really are doing
that like the 2020 rule um
and okay so this is going to make you
feel better a little bit there are
studies that show like what what if if
you take gamers that are looking at
screens with games
um vr
versus someone that's using the computer
all day long so they're typing up emails
or who knows what they're doing they're
they they are actually using their eye
muscles um
more i mean they're they're working out
like you said like they're working on
their fast twitch muscles
um they're actually working on the
response time a lot more than the person
that's just staring at the computer
screen so in a way if you had to pick
you're just working on the computer all
day long versus gaming all day long as
far as like eyes goes
you'd pick gaming
oh so so so so cognito what can they
what can we do to help cognito not lose
his eyesight
[Laughter]
yeah one thing i just want to ask
quickly though there's one thing i do
because i like to do the same i like to
turn out all the lights you know the
cavs get out of the the army
make it a thing
so for the past i would say since the
beginning of the xbox one generation
playstation 4 generation i've had bias
lights on my on my uh tvs so it is that
like that projects behind the the tv
that kind of gives you that theater
effect yeah that allows you to not
strain if you're in a pitch black room
and that's kind of that's helped me but
i don't know if there's anything
scientific behind it that kind of allows
you other than this
it's just like yeah exactly exactly so
it's going to fix your eyes and that way
the light behind the television
imagine like talking to him does it
light it up a lot no
not really
and it is like if you go to the movies
cool it looks very nice but if you go to
movie theater that's the only like that
there is that light that's kind of
behind the screen um is there any truth
to that or or should you be in a better
lit room like if you yeah so here's
here's the idea about that so when
you're when you're looking at a computer
screen or a screen
in the dark and let's say the screen's
up close so let's say you're looking at
your your monitor
so there's two two visual systems that
are linked so one is your pupil size and
so in a dark room your pupil is going to
get bigger
people what are you laughing at
thinking about dilated pupils continue
let the doc speak
so yeah your people's going to get
bigger
and but the other system that is linked
is your accommodation system or your
focusing muscles
so when you're trying to look at
something up close one system is wanting
to focus up close and one system is
wanting to relax or get bigger
and so you kind of you kind of start
fighting a little bit or your eyes start
fighting a little bit when you're in a
dim lit room because those those systems
want to work together when you focus
close your people gets
smaller when you kind of focus um far
away your pupils will get a little
bigger
and so if you're in a lit room your
pupils will get smaller and it'll
actually help you focus and strain a
little bit so that that's the idea
behind that now as far as like
damaging your eyes yeah you know if
you're looking at screen in the dark um
it won't do that so it won't like cause
retinal problems or
or or cause like your your vision to
change yeah so that that that's okay
hold up okay let me record that so i
could say i know right now can you say
yeah
cause we're gonna clip this and we're
gonna send this to bombs everywhere
now you know what you know what i dread
when i go to the eye doctor mm-hmm the
drops
oh
dilated joints oh and they'd be like you
make sure you ain't driving after this
continue i'm the only person that got
here
you know i'm sitting in my car
i don't say nothing before you get there
they're just like don't drive home
right so i'm making sure that i have my
shades on right so
i go and you know they dilate your
pupils and you like here you're fine
they check you and they do that little
blue light they get oh yeah
you get dilated you walk outside
and i thought the sun was on the floor
because
it was so damn bright and i threw my
shades on and i said yo
these shades are not working don't you
get scared what if it don't come back
oh no that that level of horror like
because they say oh it takes two hours
two to six hours i said what the hell
type of range is that like two to six
hours that's a crazy range right so i
fell on the six hour range on one of
them right
because i had to keep going back because
it's super palsy right
so
it's the
i just laid in the bed and i said please
god
god god please give me back my vision at
the end of this i need sleep
and i lay there and i go to sleep and i
woke up and i said am i okay i was like
yeah okay oh cool and i laid to my left
i said yeah the pose is still there
[Laughter]
no doubt get back
a little bit
this is actually funny hearing you guys
talk about this because i i feel like i
i uh torture people all day long
it's kind of fun funny to hear people
like yeah yeah saying like yeah you do
torture people so it's good
but i'm sorry not all you're good you're
good i mean it's absolutely not quite
like a dentist but yeah yeah you guys
you guys are up there it's yeah yeah
like it's it's the most hated for me
yeah definitely that's just probably
number one but you guys are too and
as a gay because it's like you dread you
know what you're going to get into you
either know your eyesight prescription
might have you know needs to be changed
because it's been omitted or whatever
and um the thing i have to say though
and i want to see how you feel about
this it's like for me it's like you know
something you know you you prevent you
you put off for a while then i went and
i was good that i went for my my eye
exam because they were like look you
know they did the test that you know
what king is talking about for the chin
there you do the blue light but then
they were like um we see something and
i'm like oh no
what's going on and then it's like they
had me put my thing in this other little
machine but this one was like blowing
like air at you you know what i'm saying
it was like a little yeah thing and i'm
like all right and then they're like wow
we're seeing your pressure your eye
pressure
is high so i went for another follow-up
and because again you're an optometrist
but then there's an ophthalmologist
right or something like that so yeah
that's what i guess they sent me there
and they were like look it was good that
we catch it now it's not crazy but we
see signs of a possible glaucoma in the
left eye so they want to get you on the
drops what's those beautiful drops you
mentioned off-screen with timilololol
tamales
yep there we go and i was like you know
and i got nervous i'm like oh no like
because the worst thing you want to hear
is that
something could potentially you could
lose your eyesight on something like
that's the worst thing you can hear so
they're like no this is manageable you
know you just got to take these drops
every day and you know there's people
that stay on that and it's just what it
is so obviously i know that's not
exactly your field but i just wanted to
stress like how important it is for us
as gamers to really stay on top of the
ixf
yeah so exactly what you said so you did
the right thing so the
so glaucoma is one of those sneaky
uh eye things that can come up that
usually you really you really only catch
it in the eye exam your eye pressure can
get so crazy high and you won't even
know that it's high
and so that's why we do that dreaded air
puff test or we poke your eye with the
blue light yeah
it's because we got to see if your eye
pressure is high you know to catch these
types of things so so eye exam super
important um even to catch like these
types of things because
you're you're in a good spot because you
probably caught it really early
and
if you're already doing drops then yeah
they're going to preserve your eyes for
you you'll be gaming until you're 150
years old if you're doing that so you're
yeah you're good
the funniest thing is
i grew up around these blind bats
from a long time ago right so both these
guys they had they glasses and i felt
superior yes
we're going to the restaurant and we're
looking at the menu
me with no glasses
and i'm reading the menu all confidently
until one day i go to uh
our favorite little buffet with the kids
and we're having a great time and they
give out the fortune cookies
crack my fortune cookie and usually we
have the we read it everybody reads
their fortune cookie to each other
so it comes to me
and i crack my fortune cookie and i'm
like what the hell
[Laughter]
what
yeah there it is
that's the first signs of going blind
and i said oh no
it has affected me i haven't caught the
glasses i've caught the glasses
[Music]
and i realized
i don't care what type of insurance you
have right now they do have
little glasses over here for you that is
covered under your your eye care yeah
right yeah and then they have the ones
you actually want to wear yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we got to talk about that guy
with the what's up with that the
non-fashionable glasses y'all be having
in the office y'all be trying i'm just
joking
i i go in there and you get these frames
right so um you know you look at the
frames and and you know
so i'm like okay i want these
and after they start doing your little
list and i have transition so when i go
from this space to that space and oh do
you want to save yourself from the blue
light you you want to do that we add
that to the lens they doing all of this
stuff yeah and they said 2500
yeah that that'd be uh 1850. us excuse
you
i didn't this is not a mortgage what
what's happening here
i said what what happened to the the
rent the lenses of the the rims is free
what happened to that the frames are
free those are the those are the union
frames
yeah they said exactly the but the the
the actual lenses
each one costs like 900 bucks
i'm like what this is the wildest hustle
i said what about my insurance my
insurance
here's the section for you we have a
system for you
it's like
oh
i'm walking around looking like this
it's fun stuff though it's absolutely
fun stuff your your response doctor
no
so it's um it's it's all true
so and that and it's actually hard um in
our practice because the
it's it's a weird balance because we
it's like that balance where you want to
offer
you know certain things to like patients
like that you know transitions and
you know polarized you know sunglasses
and stuff like that yeah but but you
also don't want to like like oh and oh
you know this is oh you want to put that
on there oh that's an
dollars and you want to put that on it
all right well you know you know like
you start sounding like that person and
so it's it's um it's weird and so like
so a lot of times like we at least in
our office we try and like do you know
package deals
um where it's like one price um you know
and then
it it's but it's tricky because there's
like there's there's some even like with
our lab when we pay them
for like certain like transitions
there's these like crazy polarized
transitions that transition behind the
windshield that go really fast yeah but
they're they are
expensive i mean even for us as the
office and so it's it's it's a hard
hard one to even like present that to
like the patient like hey here's
something but
it's gonna it's gonna cost a little
crazy yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be
pricey that's exactly what she said this
would be a little pricey
i'm thinking pricey 400. yes
no she said 18. i said excuse me
that's different we need that
we need that louis vuitton package
that's what we need
absolutely man we got to move on because
the timing a little bit behind but oh
yeah one thing i do really respect about
your content is the humor you know you
got the good production values you're
doing the faces but you know you're
really
informative and you have like a very
easy to understand style so what i
wanted to ask you because you're giving
out a lot of good game a lot of good
educational information in the realm on
your channel but what are some of the
videos that you personally are proud of
on your channel
so usually the ones that i are most
proud of are the ones that nobody's seen
salute
salute let's go
i don't know how that i don't know how
that happens but um
so
for example like the vr the vr videos
actually um or vr prescription lenses i
i'll be making a lot more videos of that
because those are actually the more fun
to make like
because like there's more passion behind
that it's like double passion like eye
passion and yeah vr gaming passion so
those are the more fun to make but i
mean some some of the videos where i um
go into details like about um
the
the eyes and like maybe like a certain
eye condition or something those are the
those are the videos that i actually
spend a lot of time making like
researching and everything
but nobody watches those
so it's tricky so i but i kind of make i
i serve two purposes i make a lot of
videos for my my patients and my office
too so it's kind of like a double a
double win there so gotcha
yeah no salute to you man you were
killing it you know like i said i'm glad
you took the time and spent some time in
a realm educated i think it's very
important as gamers we really need to do
a better job about it and it's really
informative and um shout out to i
thought she was going to say it was
you're most proud of was you dancing in
the office to justin bieber
[Laughter]
there's somebody as i do just for the
purpose of embarrassing my wife
that was one of
what's your level of celebrity now
at your practice it's like like do
people come in yeah be like yo dr eye
guy oh wow you doing
no no um in fact hardly anybody knows i
still i i even do that that i'm on
youtube unless they see my videos in the
office but i have had
the craziest story i had so i did a
video about getting herpes in your eye
so like a herpes
infection and
um i had a guy and he had a cold sore on
his mouth all of a sudden as i started
getting red and he was driving traveling
from california up through idaho which
is where i'm at and so he looked at
youtube he's like oh my gosh can i get
like herpes in my eye and he happens to
see my video and in that video i'm like
if you even think you have herpes in
your eye you need to go to your eye
doctor he's like oh gosh so he like
calls up you know an office you know
you know he's in the office and then i
come walking into the exam room and he's
like he's like here he's like you're the
guy i saw on youtube
you told me to go see the eye doctor you
told me to go see you and so that that
was like weird that was like that was a
weird experience
he watched your heartbeat eye video and
you told him to come this is
manifestation you brought me here yeah
this is crazy crazy small world so that
that was fun yeah that's it's fun
so we gotta solve any other question
before we wrap up with that guy yeah we
just uh a couple of super chats that are
specific like related to get questions
real quick okay let's get it uh i wanted
to get those so first off um
midway monster photo super chat does do
corrective lenses make your eyes worse
over time i have worn glasses in 20
years and my eyesight to me has remained
the same and then somebody uh dm me a
personal question about pinhole glasses
and do they really help to strengthen
your eye muscles
ooh okay so yeah um
okay so this is going by studies here
yeah okay but you'll get well you will
get some people saying one thing or the
other but studies show uh
either wearing glasses or not wearing
glasses
does not make your eyes worse does not
make the vision worse
according to studies you'll get a lot of
people to say you know oh my glasses
like killed my eyes and i understand
that there are a lot of people like that
so but studies show that it does not um
now pinhole glasses so pinhole
uh
it does
pinhole will not improve revision
but there is something called the
pinhole effect i think i
i go over in one of my videos or maybe a
couple of my videos where if you have if
you're nearsighted or even farsighted if
you take a little tiny hole you can even
punch a hole in a piece of a piece of
paper and hold it up to your eye you
will see better because you're getting
rid of all the peripheral light rays
that need to be focused there's one
light ray that goes right through the
center of your eye and doesn't need to
be focused at all and so that's where
the pinhole glasses come from
is that you're
you're looking through that pinhole and
your eyes don't need to try and focus
those peripheral light rays now as far
as it like strengthening your eye
muscles or your vision
unfortunately not doesn't it doesn't
work oh gosh yeah and then one super
one last funny super chat pragmatic
eagle 5.00 i'm reminded in chat i still
don't think that puff test is legit it's
torture and i think eye doctors enjoy it
also
don't rub your eyes with your herpe hand
oh don't do that don't do that so about
the puff test uh doctor guy is
is this a inside joke with you guys
no no no so it is legit but i mean i
mean that doesn't stop us from kind of
giggling at some people
but there is something like you'll start
seeing more in offices actually using
something called the eye care gets rid
of the eye eye puff test uh it kind of
rests it still gets really close but you
don't have to use any eye drops there's
no air puff and it still measures your
pressure so you know if you can find an
office that has the eye care you won't
have to do the air
so there you go the biggest question is
when you did that eye puff test have you
ever told a customer or a client stop
being a baby it doesn't hurt that much
you know you know what's funny is uh
you'll get like the big
big bulky guys i mean like football
players yeah yeah like king here yeah
they'll get in there and you know like
eye puff test they'll get ready and and
they're awful
you know shaking
they can't keep it over they nervous
yeah yeah
and then you'll get like this uh you
know teenage you know
14 year old small girl you know whatever
and she's like rock solid like
anything oh yes yeah i'll take i'll take
that anyway okay yeah he actually pulled
up
with the blue light and this big dude
over here is crying
offhand do you know like your office of
record for the person who took longest
to learn how to put on contact lenses
oh yeah so um uh well there's a lot of
them that just like quit you know they
give up
yeah yeah so yeah there was there was
one guy that was determined but he was
he was in there for four hours and then
we actually had to say you know maybe
you should come back because we're
closing
yeah yeah yeah it took me six hours six
hours six hours but now i just you know
now i i tell my eye my wife is like
that's disgusting
it was your first time it's okay it
takes it's okay it takes longer
and now you're a pro
last question for the rapport i wanted
to ask this cause i think i'm
disqualified for this but i had to ask
like
laser surgery and i know that's not what
you do but like
the thought process and like
you know
it is sense about quite about two-part
questions like is this kind of
conflicting with with practice you know
say if someone's like you know doing
that or is it something like you like
hey you know if if a client or someone
asks a patient about it you know you
would also direct them in that because
you know we not that we hear conflicting
things but i'm just curious about that
relationship with you know an
optometrist and a doctor and stuff like
that essentially let's be honest is
maybe steering them away from getting
glasses in your practice right so what
do you what do you feel about that so so
with me
so i
so i
um educate people that the the most
important part of the eye exam is the
eye health right and so and then what
whatever we can do to correct your
vision is like i'm all game for so
whether that's contacts glasses lasik
you know surgery for sure i mean because
i mean at the end of the day it's their
eyes and there are options out there and
so i just provide them the options and
then and then as long as i feel like
i've done my job to educate them that
hey you know as long as you're still
getting your eye health checked i mean
that's like the big thing then then
you're all good yep exactly no well said
well saying that again
we got to do better as gamers that's why
i wanted to have you on you know we have
to stay on it with the with the annual
check you know i learned a lot myself so
salute yo they calling us the i lord
podcast
podcast
salute salute
we gotta ask the question before you go
because i know tom's limited uh that we
ask all the guests in the realm
i need
dr i guys top five video games or
franchises of all time
okay so that
now i'm going off like what um memories
okay so we're going off like what
personally
this is your personal life my list if
i'm like i had to go filter back through
my my memories
so um so definitely halo series for sure
i mean
halo um
you know has a lot a lot of memories
there
uh
uh call of duty and battlefield i'll
kind of put that together just because
of like the lot a lot of nights that
were spent on
um you're kind of cheating because
that's a separate crowd because that's
the crowd go against it but i'm gonna
let you everybody's gonna hate me but
but i i
you know i feel like i showed him equal
love there so
my history there um
and then as far as like as you know
single games or like campaigns or
anything um i i loved assassin's creed i
haven't played
that
in a while so assassin's creed was a big
one for sure
um two more two see
uh oh man i had this list what uh
oh oh yeah gears of war was a big one oh
okay
and you got one last one
yeah gears of war and then uh
oh gosh um personally
yeah i know i i mean if i had to go i'd
go golden eye i mean that
of the the feelings the feelings i
remember
a little awesome list and the very final
question
favorite console of all time and why
uh well
so that would be the xbox
uh wow let's go to the xbox man if i
have to be specific
try and think what if i played the most
xbox one it'd have to be there
wait xbox og the big block or xbox one
with the connect
which xbox what the first version of the
halo not og
the one yeah real well this is the first
xbox one race
talks about the one he's played the most
so okay that's the one you played wait i
i got to hear that we just being kicked
just did a retrospective on this hold on
hold on
so so is it what was it just you played
it the most like what was the game that
you played the most that you have that
affinity for i kind of do it yes so yeah
so we're talking about xbox one right
like the xbox 360 xbox one we're talking
about that one right about the f you
talk about the first
one not the first xbox okay
i'm sorry you're accurate i'm just
shocked i've never heard this this is
great
yeah it's that next yeah played the most
i mean for sure i mean as far as like uh
online gaming
you know staying you know staying in
touch with my friends family there's
just a lot of good memories a lot of wow
so that's that's that's what it is you
know like uh
i don't think people
get like look the original xbox one
had its issues but i don't think people
give that generation enough credit and
the xbox one was part of that generation
and they contributed sure maybe not like
a whole lot in terms of games during
that generation right but it still
contributed to social facts it still
contributed the rise of destiny you know
there's so much stuff that that helped
with yeah video calling remember when
you can you can snap skype
and you know your connect could pop up
you were like uh you know connect uh uh
xbox skype and you're talking to your
grandparents across
you know all the way you know across the
country or whoever
i thought that was amazing absolutely
got to put it in there did you did you
have the one with the connector you had
the base one if you remember
uh i think i i think i had ended up
having both
okay
well he's an eye doctor and he's selling
you glasses at seven thousand dollars
everything sir oh no
salute to the first xbox one to get the
console that's what's up man so again
you you know what you you're doing the
the doctor stuff and they
like never asked of what they would
listen
absolute pleasure to have you thank you
for rock thank you for taking the time
and dealing with our technical issues
brother um
first of all salute to you what you do
absolute amazing content please
subscribe to the channel we're gonna put
his channel out there y'all go check em
out dr eye guy really awesome we're not
the eye we're not the iron eye podcast
stop it so
they're going crazy with the things so
what's going on to the i iron pot
podcast
now we need now we need a
uh
a picture with the the logo the eye in
the middle yeah the third eyes open the
third is over but look man love what you
do again the humor the education do it
in a cool way really helpful where can
you find people find you what else do
you have going on
yeah so so main channels the dr eye guy
on on youtube i mean i do also have a
instagram uh twitter facebook but
definitely
more of my internet interaction is
definitely on youtube for sure and so
i'll have a lot more uh gaming eye vr
videos coming out i have a lot more
planned right now so it's uh it's going
to be exciting and they're going to be
fun ones to make too a vr contact so i'm
going to oh your contacts is one that'll
be coming out here in a little bit oh
okay okay yeah let us know definitely
check it out put his channel in the
description uh lord addict let's get um
some outros for doctor i got let's set
them off right
appreciate you coming on uh i always
like to have like different perspectives
of stuff that like affects gaming or
stuff in gaming in general and it was
nice to hear yours no doubt
absolutely lord solve but we got
forgotten i got all the way out oh yeah
man i i love your content i mean as
somebody who's blind as hell
five years old a representative of the
blind community we love library
so
it was just great to you know have this
issue with the oculus and immediately
just find your content and to find that
again not everyone is able to
to to
kind of
share their knowledge in a way that's
kind of simple to digest for everyone
and kind of comedic as well uh i i love
what you're doing i i just cool wish you
all the success in the world
thank you thank you lord king
talking about those issues those issues
anybody that can listen uh to 50 cent
and michael jackson and the in the green
room he ain't know what he would get
into
actually jam on and say yeah i'm down
with this i like how this feels
had a great time i and you know i had my
questions uh for you since like last
night i'm thinking i'm like oh we got
one this is this is gonna be incredible
and we get a chance to see um how
diverse our community is yes and what it
encompass and encompass doctors from all
different degrees and all different
ranges lawyers and stuff like that and
it bridges the gaps and it takes away
the fear because a lot of times people
don't go to the eye doctor until there's
something
you know and
hopefully this changes that whole
conversation and they see that you're
not a monster you're a person
and they can actually go to the eye
doctor without the fear you know and um
and i think this will do that because oh
and they will go to your content and see
that you know
we
have
different type of people in our
community and i'm so happy that you're
here today
and you really helped me with a couple
of things because i know that fourth
nerve pose and he was like wow he really
dealing with something like that
and then it's cool it's cool to have a
doctor on i can actually say that's cool
no doubt
yeah thanks for having me on i've been
excited about this for i mean ever since
you invited me on here so i i've been
thinking about it like i said i was like
getting my mic ready and everything and
so i i was like this is like i thought
about every day oh man it's gonna be
awesome so this this is an honor i loved
it
and we'll have you back the legendary
optometrist doctor i got go subscribe to
the channel focus in do what you got to
do i like what yeah yeah yeah focus in
that's right focus it brother
put his channel in the uh in the chat
yeah i've been putting the channel in
there i don't know if he's there so i've
been putting it but look brother enjoy
your sunday i know you got super bowl
you got the brisket go take care we got
a big show and we'll have you back in
the room hopefully again okay thanks so
much
all right please see ya bye no doubt so
everybody super chats
yeah we had a couple of super chats
um not not too many i read the ones that
were
messy they were i related yes i
yeah we got bearded panda two dollar
super chat yo king where's that link for
the 10k
[Laughter]
dragon heart yobe tv 20 super chat
hashtag peace love life lords a double o
seven rumor is credible
the achievement list popped up on true
achievements as well king david great
combo on dragon's den
cognito man man man you're making grown
men cry out here we are proud hashtag
legend no doubts thank you brother my
brother's making me look good man if it
wasn't for my brothers
when i had to jump on uh 108 dragons
yesterday they were talking about some
scale-bound stuff and
[Music]
i had to tell them it wasn't what you
thought there was we will get to it
during that time continue
um then we have hard to find five
dollars of chat lord he hit me from
behind with that little
i'm thing to throw you in the bushes sir
here you go
continue
then we have oh no it's alex
5 super chat
xbox for the streets david don't forget
to bend your knee
once again that is not how knees work
you know what's funny and no disrespect
alley we love alex i i know i i didn't
know who out you know me i'm not yeah
you're not on youtube i didn't know who
alex was until i went and saw and then
now i know
now you know
you know and and and i think it's cool
but you know instead of next incredible
dude
oh my god all we will say for alex again
i usually stay out of the messy this is
that first of all we gotta get you
around follow me on twitter i've been
trying to get you on the show so follow
me i'm calling you out now because it's
clearly been saying you doubted it but
you ain't doing it so i've been calling
it up so salute to him luke depressed
all podcasts love those guys alex is
killing it right now salute him but um
the rules like king and everyone's
saying the rules of engagement is you
got to put your knee on the line and say
something's not going to happen versus
something's going to happen and that's
how i mean
there was xbox no he did the leg though
i officially lost it when he picked up
the the chair
he shook the legs
we we gotta we gotta talk about the the
manson peepers though cause when he
laughs he has these these the man i'm
like there's something wrong with you
alex
salute to the homies
salute to the hobie we're gonna do that
yo follow me on twitter
yeah so um gerald back what do we have
five dollar chat oh hello i'll pee
salute just had a road trip from oakland
to detroit 2500 miles in 35 hours love
the six-hour show that's what i was
talking about yeah
yeah we
he put up a video that he was in
nebraska and he was like it seemed like
he was trying to get out of nebraska as
quickly as possible
now leo lyon see now that is a knee bet
yeah like with the gt7 and him and bl
those are bets that's how we go that's
how you lose your deeds
yeah he's gonna he's gonna lose his
nieces it's gonna be two days push back
oh my god
then we got splendiferous two dollar
super chat who is this guy i feel like
he needs a trophy talk about doctor i
yeah
yeah uh let me see let me roll back a
little bit that was it okay cool we all
caught up let's get into the poll sony's
recent acquisition of bungie which
outcome do you think is most likely to
happen as a result of this with the uh
basically oh no no no i'm blogging
yeah the winner of the four-way isle
poll at uh close 35 percent of the vote
was bungee and sony's match will clash
long-term in philosophy leading to an
eventual split once again coming in at
second place at 29 of the vote was the
messy laws i don't care i'm all about
this natural and organic growth of
acquisitions
in third place at 25 percent of the vote
budgie will now have proper financial
support for destiny and new franchises
plus leverage sony tv and film
connections and in last place with only
nine percent of the vote with sony's
multiplayer and live service offerings
will be enhanced with bungie's expertise
group lord addict how are we feeling
about the realm feeling that it might
break up long term
uh
i don't know it's just one of those
things where we're gonna have to see
what happens
i don't trust the whole matter i i i got
i gotta be proven wrong
she has never been in a long-distance
relationship and stay committed
she's in the streets oh here we go
yeah yeah xbox for the streets too
let's just get right to it
your hopes is for the streets
you got hopes and prayers
let's get right to it this is solved
jumped on this immediately in the
internal iop channel i don't see my
topic hey playstation
thanks for having me on the show it was
an audio thank you brother you were
amazing you killed it you will be
backing around man absolute pleasure so
let's get to it man awesome
we're not a street talk
let's let's get this was your time you
quickly put this into the realm to let
us know what was going on so before i
break it down i just want to reiterate
it give me my diamonds just give me my
diamonds
if some of you may recall a video that i
put up not you know not too long ago uh
and and and in that video i say
something specific
about
i would do with call of duty what
minecraft
is is right now
and that's and that's
and and that's what it is so just give
me my doubts listen
when you pull the clip back and you said
active i'm like i don't even remember
what he said but continue me neither
yeah i ain't remember him who is this
guy yeah call me now call me back okay
sorry cleo so in in the wake of uh the
playstation acquisition of bungie and uh
the fact that they indicated that all
the destiny was going to stay
multi-platform and bungie's games moving
forward we're going to be multi-platform
benefits
waiting for the streets
president of microsoft brad excuse me
brad smith yes in an interview with cnbc
under the referendum
oh my god here we go
i know
i know what
[Laughter]
go for it because i'm going to break
this down and put it right in the bushes
let's go
so
in an interview with cnbc yes sir under
directions
non-credible outlet cnbc
microsoft president brad smith indicated
that uh
once the acquisition goes through should
it go through without an issue uh they
would not be preventing future activism
blizzard games and call of duty from
being released on playstation consoles
design
their desire to read the stuff there we
go let's get it but say it let's look
look let's saw that let me uh again let
me read the question
the whole i got the code in front of me
i got the query
one of the things we're being very clear
about as we move forward with the
regulatory review of this acquisition is
that what they're doing they underwent
move forward where's the under what no
you said no no no you said there i i'm
sorry i i just didn't hear you just then
could you please say that last part
again they under what type of review
as we move forward with the regulatory
review okay
if you ask me a question it's not duress
we gotta have to put time one kick until
we can read the statement yeah let's go
for it let's do the time we get to that
people who don't know what we're talking
about i know
is that great this is misdirection by
kick is that great titles like call of
duty from activision blizzard today will
continue to be available on the sony
playstations
[Music]
he then added
quote we'd like to bring it to nintendo
devices we'd like to bring the other
popular titles that activision blizzard
has and ensure that they continue to be
available on playstation
and that they become available on
nintendo end quotes right hold us up i
got something else like where you read
that one because i got the one from this
is vgc all right so here's the thing for
microsoft he said for some first some
commentators have asked whether we will
continue to make popular content like
call of duty available on competing
platforms like playstation the obvious
concern is that microsoft could make
this title available exclusively on the
xbox console undermining opportunities
for sony playstation users to be clear
microsoft will continue to make call of
duty and other popular activision other
popular activision blizzard titles
available on playstation through the
term of any existing agreement with
activision and we have committed to sony
that we will also make them available on
playstation beyond the existing
agreement and into the future so that
saudi fans can continue to enjoy the
games they love we are also interested
in taking similar steps to support
nintendo's successful platform we
believe that this is the right thing for
the industry for gamers and for our
business
i mean now i'll round it out i'll let
you guys go first i'll round everything
out at the end let's go ahead
let's kick just wanna adding stepping
away for this it's whoever will like yes
okay because clearly clearly
it should be added
so all you frauds out there
talking all this hotness
king xbox for the streets
xbox x that's your hopes and your dreams
yeah warzone you can have that it's free
to play it will be everywhere it says
call of duty at the top of it so it is
actually a popular title it's a popular
title from activision other popular
titles from activision is other games of
service that you can actually have on
your platform yes this is true this is
for you and if you feel that that's xbox
for the streets well listen then that
part is for the streets you can't equate
one company telling you
everything we do
is out there
to another that's
that one was under no regulatory
concerns this one is under a hell of a
lot of scrutiny it's like when you take
a piss test and you smoke some weed a
couple weeks ago you're trying to figure
out if you go past but you try to make
sure everything goes through let's let's
look or you're looking at your credit
score to see if you can actually get
that car and you're actually hoping that
it goes through so right now microsoft
is in that it's hoping it goes through
and it's going to say and do everything
at this point in time to make sure that
stuff goes through now i know a lot of
you guys are going to say oh but they
can't go back on their word king
a lot of politicians do it every day
oh boy
listen i actually heard somebody said
that they believe in generations and
they turn right around
that wasn't a deal for it but this this
that was a deal he made with you he made
a deal with you and you agreed to the
deal he said all our stuff going forward
will be in the new generation he lied to
you
under regulation you feel you cop you
cop your stuff and you thought it was
next generation and you realize that the
dude who said now i i'm not gonna buy
that can do the same thing that you're
doing and playing the same thing that
you're doing so lies happen to you all
the time and this is where the lie
happened they would like they would
desire they all these little words
that's being used in there keep popping
up i desire to be a millionaire i would
like to be rich right now
but guess what's happening at this point
in time now maybe later that stuff could
happen but at this moment right now
no
i'm not going behind a yacht with phil
but
this is what's gonna happen when those
deals dry up and that ink dries and
those little contracts that they have
run out and at 2023
and these dudes are saying yeah
2024 we gonna get that new call of duty
we desire to put it there
at this point in time we don't have an
absolute resolution to give to you so
what you're going to do is have this war
zone and be happy we're going to have to
have this intervention with king some i
see yeah all right so
what we're gonna have to talk about is
to be clean right yeah
he's going he's going down with the ship
and i respect that i respect going down
with the ship i'll respect that he's
like he's like leonardo dicaprio yeah
he's the lion yeah
the music the band playing and the [ __ ]
got a clear hole in it
so so be clear king just so for the
record right you you feel that even
though they say they are going to
continue for call of duty specifically
right so you don't believe that and they
also said other popular activism
like so so so so what about like there's
other games or services that will
definitely go down so you so do you not
think overwatch 2 diablo those are
popular
yes okay so you think it will be for the
streets oh no no i see that's not for
the streets if you're saying like
overwatch 2 games like that
definitely should be all over okay right
i'm you're talking about games with a
service so then you agree with us on on
on you agree with us you agree with us
the only thing you did certain games
that are exclusive listen i don't think
call of duty is a game of service
okay so so so
you're so i think the only thing we
disagree then is that be solvent and
attic first you is that
you just think call of duty is the only
game you you don't know i believe diablo
i believe a lot of the games
are going to stay on the xbox platform
game pass now if game pass is available
right on a competing platform right yeah
it'd be over there but i feel gains of a
s with a service those those games
they're going to keep memory they're
going to be all over the place and they
need to be so you don't consider
call of duty that because i'm just
trying to understand like that's not
call of duty the campaign i'm talking
about you know the multiplayer aspect
and they're not going to break it up
into oh you just get the multiplayer and
that's going to be over there no i don't
believe call of duty is a game of
service and and that's going to be there
but warzone is it's a free-to-play game
with a service okay and i believe that
will be
available like minecraft all over the
place so again
call of duty 2024 or whatever 2025
whatever on track is that when the
contract is up you feel they will be
call of duty will not be on playstation
i believe they're gonna say uh we desire
and then that's when they're and
again if if if warzone didn't say call
of duty at the top right
you know this is a caveat that's that's
the part where
we can give you war zone it's call of
duty right
so do you think uh the the the regulator
that doesn't play games knows exactly
the difference between call of duty war
zone and call of duty so
you
you know what i you know what i don't
like
in this part this is the part
when
sony got bungee
i didn't give a rats you know behind
what they did with it right didn't care
right
when microsoft
news broke that they purchased
activision or we're in the process of
purchasing activision
oh well it doesn't matter call of duty
ain't crap anyway we don't care
this is the toughest cry babies i've
ever seen in my life
like y'all are the the strongest tear
jerking crybabies i've ever seen one
minute is
oh we don't care about that but please
mr president
don't let my call of duty go away
i thought you didn't like it you thought
it was trash
so
in the same cry babies when they got
bungee we got halo i thought halo was
trash
so these same tough babies
out here snitching
but i need you to check his paperwork
that doesn't go through it wait you
ain't blind
microsoft has been paying their taxes
properly and could you look at line 34
because i honestly believe monopoly
yourself is doing something different
that shouldn't happen
i don't want call of duty but i won't
call it dude
go away you're ridiculous
you know what i do hope i hope
i hope it does come out on playstation
and i hope it's 75 dollars let's get to
it pay for it but it will be my game
pass for free
every time you boot it up i want
microsoft uh activision call of duty to
pop up and i want the price tag to fly
across the screen
75
we got you again i want you to fund my
fun ridiculous i want all your money
to fund my game password i want you to
buy all the call of duty games so we can
buy more acquisitions and have more
games and game pass
that's what i want but y'all gonna get
warzone and i really think it's gonna
happen
okay so you stand up addict's back if we
try to add get your bike up is it good
can you hear me yes yes i guess yeah
we're trying to have an intervention
here with one lord we see him
[Laughter]
how are you feeling
how about king on this square he's going
down with the [ __ ] for that he's
thinking say call of duty he he actually
agrees with us though he says i
overwatch diablo
but he said they gonna get warzone they
not getting call of duty go ahead
so alex this is how you officially take
kings these is that is that [ __ ] worth
your knees what is he actually for call
of duty for call of duty is that no me
me making the bed not you you taking the
bat
yeah how about three us three first
things i gotta get from you dude like i
don't know i think these are official
gone needs yo you are actually wolverine
because you grow back more appendages
than i've ever seen in my life to stop
diverting all right so so you know we
don't i don't yeah yes but this isn't
we're gonna we're not gonna know this
for another we're not gonna notice until
yeah this is
one of those bets it's the same thing
five more peonies it's the same thing
like betting on kings you know like
there will be no playstation console the
whole generation so it's one of those
things we you know it's really you can't
quantify the times 24 with your knees
i can't anyway back to attic what do you
think in general like about this whole
thing and where are you at after this
when you heard this news it just i think
they were strictly doing it because
they're scared that if they don't make
statements like this
that the government might shut the whole
deal down so you know
wait wait wait you said they just said
that just to say that
because they don't want them to shut it
down so either you believe it or you
don't
they're
i don't think that they're going to make
open statements like that and then just
go back oh
i don't think they're going to pull a
reverse uno card
i didn't say that not us
we're just talking about this app store
we didn't know
the people who take
like the next mantle unless they blame
phil's mantle well i don't know what
phil them was saying but this isn't what
we were going to do
something like that where like the next
gen of people that take over xbox blame
the pastor
that you know the obligations that they
made doesn't affect what they want to do
i just don't see them openly coming out
on national tv they say we lied like
yeah yeah and i don't think it's a
situation either it's not a lot you got
cooking out of town you got call of duty
sit down maybe you didn't get the big
juice box but you got juice now sit down
and drink your juice i'm done let me
jump in okay so shout out to uh
microsoft president brad smith the one
that's awesome shout out to him telling
you you getting call of duty he said
that the company is focused
what you didn't want to hear but what
you need to hit
exactly
is it isn't warzone very popular it's a
popular title right no it is it is it's
a call of duty right thank you yeah
absolutely he said um the company's
focused on creating an app store that
will enable any gamer on any device to
access any app this announcement comes
on the heels of its proposed activity
acquisition of activision blizzard which
is expected to face regulatory scrutiny
smith tells cnbc that microsoft wants to
adapt to the regulation and not fight
against it you know i'm kind of with
sophie in the sense that yo
first i got this wrong because
i thought that this was definitely i was
in king's corner to be honest with you
with how this was he was call of duty so
the date was announced me and uh me and
cog went out a little bit over it yeah
so he was very strong i was very strong
i'm like my thing is i'm following the
president i'm following the bethesda
situation and i'm like okay this is how
i was gonna go forward you use the
little legal speaker whatever whatever
to me though
i gotta give this like i i i feel i'm
wrong i got to give jess courtney his
flowers because he called this as well
he was like he felt that call of duty
what's the word of your shelter just
he's a ritual and it's such a big
franchise that the deal i think this is
my feeling
under normal circumstances you know what
i'm saying if this wasn't as big as it
was
and then we have the regulatory thing
going on then it may it it's microsoft's
desire
to want to make this that way the
problem is i gotta say like i said on
duke the feds is watching
the feds is watching and and to me when
you make a statement and you gotta put
this this is a preemptive proactive
statement like they jumping in for like
no one's checking the books nothing yet
they're like yo for the record we're
doing an app store this thing we're
doing is going to be great for
development to me this feels like a pr
campaign hey we're the good guys we
don't rip everything away from everybody
we're okay
where's the
why are you bringing nintendo name in
here why is the nintendo name in here
like no it's just for the record we
would desire to bring it over there too
like this is to be
this dude i was like nobody saw nobody
talking like yo why are you calling me
like yo because it's like to me the
fence is on you this deal must go down
at all costs
and we have to be clear this is the most
comp this is not just cinemax
xenomax is games
that's games you got king
no pun intended you know what i said who
uh it's a whole you got the deal done a
whole mobile arm being added to you
right then you got blizzard and
battlenet a pc
arm added to you then the argument the
number one game of all time the most
selling game of all time period boss
on your platform and in a perfect world
it was up to them they'd be like yeah we
keep it there just like we did bethesda
but because of the structure and now
this moves them into the third place
that's the part i had i always gave just
this i have to give myself some credit i
said i do understand the logic but they
say you know what we may have to make
concessions the lawyers come in the room
like bro
this is such a complex deal we can't
afford for this thing to get held up so
if the concession is yo you make call of
duty everywhere else and then okay maybe
an overwatch maybe that and then
everything else from moving forward
that's new or whatever is exclusive that
may be the thing to get the deal because
that deal done because they can't afford
this thing let's be honest it fell in
the lab it fell in they didn't go out
actively searching activision activision
had the scandal they was looking crazy
the building's on fire someone hit up
saatchi like this is the last bit and
it's like we gotta make this happen
we'll never get an opportunity like okay
this is one of those things where
they're like
this deal is too good to sound too good
and if we have to give
certain games over there we will do that
because at the end of the day like i
said uh they they kind of want to dip
their finger their toes a little bit
when it comes to other
it's like i've said multiple times
we do the gaming industry but the video
entertainment industry
they're fighting more for ips to make tv
shows about right and when you buy all
of activision you have overwatch you can
literally make a show on every character
you have diablo that's a show by itself
like you have
spyro right
crash bandicoot is so much microsoft can
literally lease every single one of
these out to these giant places like uh
like amazon netflix because they're
paying top dollar for this stuff do you
think that uh that they put that halo
show on what's that painter
you think they put that on there and the
kindness of the heart no because they
put cold hard cash in microsoft's hand
here's the thing let's be real you know
the argument before we i'm with king in
the sense that i know like a lot of
people this is why this is a very unique
situation a lot of people were like yo
remember center max yo they got to put
it on playstation because it's something
you know so they got they gotta they got
to make their money right we know based
on the warchest of microsoft they don't
need that the long plays get you in to
game pass at any cost and if they have
these titles that's gonna a thing but i
will say this for the people because
i've seen a lot of vitriol of like fan
xbox fans very upset very bad
yeah like they're very upset and i'm
like like that doesn't you know first of
all death threats and stuff like that
yeah but i wasn't fake that one was fake
yeah that was fake
and stuff like that that's that's
idiotic uh ridiculous and and you really
need to stand down off of that because
at the end of the day
whatever microsoft decides to do with
these ips going forward if they decide
to make them for everything i believe
all new uh ip's are just to be inside
game pass and to be for them unless it's
a game with a service i believe games
with services is going to be prevalent
throughout uh if and if it's possible on
every console because it's reoccurring
revenue engagement
that
works in that ecosystem now there's an
argument to say that uh call of duty
makes x amount of dollars in in this
thing but they also said that they're
going to shut down the cadence of every
year
so
does it happen that okay you get call of
duty after it's already been on xbox for
a year but you actually get a call of
duty you know at uh
in in the following year
so
it's it's it's a really tricky thing and
yeah do do they have to uh placate the
regulatory system and and uh the the
the ftc
uh to to that that's that's actually
watching
yeah you have to placate that stuff and
you have to play nice and you have to
see that you're not becoming a monopoly
and you're not becoming uh this over uh
watching a bully
i like that
bully uh in the industry yeah and i also
believe that's the same reason why when
sony purchased uh bungie they agreed to
certain concessions because uh the
outcry would be so crazy that
what are you gonna do with uh uh destiny
2 right on xbox or we're going to go
back to you having exclusive uh deals
for a year and stuff like that so right
these these companies is looking
at
what helps them
at the end of the day it's really not us
as far as what we desire in this fake
console war crap but it's exactly the
bottom line and they're there to make
money so if it's going to be on another
console and it's going to make money
they're going to do it look you know so
yeah just to finish up what i was saying
um
pretty much what you said and then i'm
sorry that was that
yeah i was just going to say that
there might be a good chance because you
know we did hear that
the studios are really interested and
microsoft kind of entertained it a
little bit but didn't really ever come
out openly and say that call of duty
might start going by yearly
so microsoft's mindset might be look
look we're going to still do call of
duty and put give it everywhere but it's
not going to be the same call of duty
because we're doing it every other year
i mean so at that point i mean they
already talked about that the new one
this year is on a different engine and
they're already making changes to call
of duty right um
i i just don't know when you think about
call of duty right and this might be
counter with to what we've been talking
about let's say these these these three
development studios want to continue
making call of duty right they don't
want to go through something else or
whatever the case may be right
so how do you how do you give them the
time to make it unique and special each
time it comes out even if you're still
releasing at a regular cadence of a year
right that's the yeah could you kind of
almost like you'll kind of almost have
to add a team so that you give it to
each team four years to make a game
instead of three right
it's kind of weird that way i don't know
what they plan on doing but what i do
know is that from a business perspective
and we said this before you don't buy
that to stop the gravy train i
absolutely want them to increase the the
what the property is and and make it not
so see me from year to year i absolutely
want that but at the same time you have
to try to do that without stopping the
stop in the bag that's a huge bag it's
cute for us to say yeah they could take
their time and
bruh every year this thing kills this is
what they have division in trouble
themselves because it's like yo it's
such a money maker okay and this is why
it feels like a game as a service every
year because even when the this year's
game isn't super well received
it feels which it feels if it sells like
hotcakes anyway right and two
it feels so disposable because you know
in less than 12 months you're getting
another one and that that kind of sucks
in of itself because you spent three
four years making this game and
you have a year window for that game to
be the thing but that's it i think
microsoft could be looking at it it's
like look like
maybe there is starting to become a call
of duty
um what's wrong fatigue fatigue because
every year the cells go down and down
and they're like maybe they do need an
every other year thing and you know
you got like four or five studios making
call of duty right like and it's not
like these studios didn't make good
gains before they got pushed to call of
duty like my thing is if if
if microsoft is true
on that we want you to make what you
want to make
but they still want to keep the call of
duty train going i don't see them
forcing every studio to make call of
duty because that goes completely
against what they talk about i don't
feel like all five of those studios in
that support studio all of them are
going to want to continue making calls i
feel you and in a perfect world i i feel
you the only problem is now
if it goes down the way it goes down
right now right and this goes this joint
stays on playstation and whatever but
let's be real it being on game pass is
an attractive
deal like that is huge hey call of duty
it's to me it's the same thing and i
actually might breathe life into the
frame right because now be like yo i got
no excuse not to play it it's on game
pass i ain't got to pay the 70 i'm in
right so they should seek tremendous
engagement off that but also we got to
remember
that 70 30 cut on playstation and
microsoft was eating on the platform
because if playstation has more of the
base or whatever at the time and every
call of duty sold here come me what's
the the cartoon
you one for you one two three for me
like every joint like that's hard for
someone to say yeah we're gonna stop
that and we're gonna we're gonna you
know it sound good i would love to see
it they are they they mention it i just
find it it's funny interesting not
saying that they're not i just find it
interesting to see if they actually
follow through with it because that is a
ton of money now that they own
activision blizzard if they put it on
playstation if they but the fact that
they mentioned it so they got nothing to
do with this which is like what you call
about nah nah we thinking about because
we want to put it there too and like
we do got to consider that we don't know
if this dude because we've we've seen
scenarios in the past where
executives have spoke on situations that
they're not up to date with oh for sure
and they just throw out stuff that they
acknowledgingly know like for instance
there was the
um the the executive at sony that
literally told you what miles morales
was like literally told you what it was
and then he got pulled to the side
pretty much and they made that article
come down yeah because it was just like
he knew what was going on but he didn't
know
what was actually going on yeah so you
could literally just have an executive
that
he
he is going what he thinks the company
is because sometimes there's pr
nightmares they don't really communicate
with people
though like the only difference is like
they're talking like this app store
like utopian environment where they're
gonna make it great
we're not going to monopolize we're
we're working with regulation guys like
we like this is the ultimate pr good
guys kumbaya rainbow sunshine i've never
seen like they ain't even the
investigation is starting but it's we so
early the fact that they put out this
statement to say that to me speaks
volumes that this deal got the goal was
crazy i i don't understand
i still don't understand why they'd be
terrified at this like we've already
shown that this only puts them in third
place behind tencent and sony no they're
terrified that they're going to get shut
down not that it's not going to go
through like that i feel like
that that the activision does going to
get shut down that's why they're
i can almost guarantee you right now
that they have no problem you're both in
agreement yeah both for the group
i can guarantee you right now that they
have no problem 100
putting everything activision
activision and blizzard on all consoles
before they lose that deal no no both
agree yeah
this is the thing though right this is
where i like their their vision still
confuses me right because if you think
about
what they've said about game pass from
the very beginning
and and there's hope that that game pass
is going to be everywhere that's that
and the other if that really is the hope
then that was then this was always the
plan to be honest like let's keep it
real this is always the plan the problem
is that maybe sometimes when you think
about and i've said this in the past
when you think about
the nitty gritty of putting game pass
everywhere
that means that everywhere except pc and
xbox consoles the game pass experience
is inferior to what you're getting on
those platforms so you have to you have
to get those companies to agree to an
inferior experience
on their platform of your games so when
when the realities of that stuff sets in
then you have to start saying okay maybe
this is not going to work for everybody
just yet we're not there yet how do we
how do we do this right and then when
you see playstation you know say hey
if we want to keep making the type of
games that we're making what happened to
the network
we're gone no we back we're back okay
you got your back
back yeah yeah
yeah
so the thing is
let's
say
if we
for
they have to think about what bungie
said and what playstation said and be
like okay this we're just going to play
nice with these type of games from now
on do i think do i think
do i think overwatch in overwatch 2 is
going to be everywhere yes do i think
there's an opportunity for uh other
blizzard games to be everywhere
can we see some kind of some kind of
resurgence for world of warcraft
everywhere even hearthstone that's on
tablets and phones put it on the console
let's see what happens like so for me
anything that requires
a community around it to be successful
on both ends of the spectrum
i think that's going to be everywhere
and when you even when you look at
nintendo we'll talk about the directing
a little bit when you look at nintendo
and some of the things that are on their
platform and what they're doing with
some of their games even them in their
own nintendo grandpa kind of way are
even looking at that so for me these
games live across all platforms i really
do believe that and when it comes to
everything else they're single player
yeah nope software's over here no elder
scrolls over here single player game
anything that requires a community
around it to be successful and makes
money that way i mark my words it's
going to be everywhere i got both of
them i got where you're going but i got
to kind of i got something what i'm
adding but addicts
in it i think that when it comes to the
overall perspective on stuff like that
it's like look i i agree with you so and
i do
but
i do feel like
in terms of
what they want to achieve
if
if it's not in game pass i don't see why
they would let some of these games go
like there's a difference between games
that were already existing on a platform
and not like for instance like that's
why you haven't seen like everborn or
whatever that show that game's called or
the
um the the other rare game whatever that
is called ever wild
boys
for like playstation you're not seeing
this red wall or red fall or whatever
that game's called for by our kind
that's a games as a service that's not
getting announced for playstation that's
xbox like
i do
i feel like they would already announce
that though if it's on playstation like
the fact that you we ain't seeing
nothing on that i mean
if you want to get technical
uh grand trip graham uh forza horizon is
is a games as a service performance of
the games why isn't that on all
platforms like
you clearly see that
there is some kind of weird messaging
that's what i was just that's why i'm
about to get it but just think about how
long those games take to make and these
these are these are obviously they did
they have plans right moving forward but
these types of shifts in the in the
industry are ones that we haven't seen
for sure i think when it comes to this
we got to see if activision is the
exception right
that's where that's where i was going
because i said this is where
look i get it
the feds is watching i get it i get it
playing nice and i look i i i get it
but the problem i have is they are going
to get themselves in trouble with the
next acquisition because it's going to
be an x acquisition right and what's
going to happen is regulate i got
regulators but the media or someone's
going to say hey microsoft just acquired
wb
hey microsoft just i guess sega
microsoft just acquired i oh
let's say microsoft puts out the
statement and they say
where game pass exists or whatever right
they say the people gonna say wait a
minute
you just said you wanted to open your
borders and you want to you you know how
much the other platforms love and you
want them to continue to play these
games and that's where the problem
starts because now you cause there's two
examples now with two totally different
actions and now people are gonna say but
wait you can't say that because you just
did this with zettabyte and then and now
like which one is it you see i say and
that's the part that gets tricky because
it it could come back to power in your
face if you continue to go back to the
original plan and make everything
exclusive like how you were doing with
the xbox game studios the obsidians the
ninja theories the zenimax and all that
and then people gonna say but wait call
of duty and activision you did xyz
that's where it gets tricky for them and
that's what i want to model do you think
do you think they open their mouth
without thinking when they said and
obviously that is a big company but when
they say they want a game pass
everywhere and they that expectation
rides with people because when you think
about it in a way if you want to make
stuff if you want to make stuff
exclusive
because of the things i said about how
game pass would exist on other platforms
it just it makes it diff it makes it a
difficult sell right so it makes it
difficult so so
now when they want to put something
exclusive
it's like okay
and and then all this talk about
ubiquity across other platforms now the
the best thing the best version of that
exclusive is on your on your platforms
and nowhere else exactly and now the
thing is going to come down to
it opens up
is the are these the new rules
and the sad part about it are no rules
the sad part about it is when activision
was a first announced
it was over like no one said anything no
one questioned anything everyone's like
these are exclusive
there's no reason they're not to be but
now since they're they're kind i would
say look i do understand
that when it comes to this thing
it's it's one of those
this landed on our lap
we have to do stuff because we want this
that we want this franchise because
theoretically they could go ahead
rebuild activision get it back on the
line and they could sell that thing for
probably way more than they bought it
for in a few years but it's just like
because of this
this purchase that you made now you have
people again questioning are they
telling the truth about starfield are
they telling the truth about this yeah
people are going to be like yo after
certainly well what thoughtful
software's a new ip but there's still
people who are going to say
well now elder scrolls could be because
you know
you know down the road yeah after
activision was bought no one was
questioning that no one was and they and
they went out their way to let you know
that you know where game pass exists
right it's just interesting that's that
that's the thing because it's like
moving forward they're gonna have to
really be very specific on their
reasoning and thought process if they
intend to make stuff exclusive again now
maybe
i don't know how you guys feel about
this but you think it's possible
that originally that was the deal that's
what they were going to do but maybe
something happened between them and sony
in that couple days and maybe game
passes phil kick i gotta ask you this
phil did get on the phone and was like
we had great conversations with soldie
and then so what if the rules of
engagement has changed and it's like
okay
all this stuff is going to go everywhere
but hey what about this game pass now
going on i got a question what about
what about this azure now going forward
what if whatever he does let me finish
the question you know say like what if
that's the new rules king where it's
like okay y'all don't want game pass and
we we heard y'all right because phil
let's be up filling the team they want
game pass everywhere they want azure
they azure is the i hate the people that
they moving powder that's the powder
that's the weight they move and they
want everyone to try this we feel we got
the best
you know what i'm saying product
so
if they got it on there and they said
okay you always resisted to the game
pass but okay it's call of duty we i get
i'm special i'm just having fun y'all
you know you know whatever we open that
up yo bungee what if bungie was the
olive branch they all right bunji we
opened that up for y'all you know what
i'm saying nintendo what's up we don't
think i think they knew about it that's
what i'm saying like what what if they
what if we all respect you
i don't think that i do think now i have
a question for king uh answer that after
i say this but
me ran
and cog was in an xbox live party and we
was arguing yes on what it would take
for playstation to cave and put game
pass on on playstation right or what it
would take
that they make those games natively for
the playstation yeah it would have to be
natively it would
but all might see the thing is is like
we've seen it on xbox when you give such
a great deal and a great value such as
game pass people are going to when it
comes to xbox's games let's be real if
game pass was on playstation the the
actual
software sales of those games are going
to draw well
when it comes to xbox games now i
personally feel like i i'm probably
wrong on this i this is what i'm what
you i
what would be hilarious is if they make
a game pass for playstation but it only
got bethesda and activision
yeah for sure but it goes back to the
whole thing like if i'm i'm a
playstation gamer right and i don't have
any intention on engaging with with the
xbox ecosystem on hardware and i just
want those games i'ma feel the type of
way that i'm going to pay 15 a month for
the same service someone else is getting
or whatever i'm going to be paying
it to get it only once you already have
that now with ea access so many 360
games are there and they're not on the
ps4
uh five counterpoint and but my question
to king king
i know phil got his full name
but at that man no strong arms no
playstation to put game pass you know on
their platform i feel like he got a he
there got to be some kind of ascension
going on no um
his name isn't a parody
right so you know for maybe for a lot of
other people it it it's uh it's a parody
for them and i hear people you gotta
give them another name king i don't just
willy-nilly give out names but this
isn't just willy nilly stuff this is
something this is the aurelius is the
golden one that's it
you don't ascend any further than that
all he
is taking it to a space he just got a
lifetime achievement award bro
he's in a different rarefied air yeah he
was talking to sony they have a relation
and i believe that you know jim is
complicit
at all points in time um does he want
game pass did he want game pass on
nintendo he won game pass on your
refrigerator he won game pass in your
tesla he won game pass everywhere right
you know um and that's not a far fetched
idea that that that stuff could happen
it could be a a future where
these are uh apps that they just app
yeah
in the cloud they both use the the azure
uh uh cloud system so
listen
would it happen
if that happens i think they're backing
out of the console space
if they have grey with you i agree all
right because at that point in time
it wouldn't make any sense right do you
see a possibility but again the rules
are so different it nothing makes sense
right now it's a question
i could see them continuing to make a
box i could see them continue to make a
box and still become the biggest
quote-unquote third-party publisher
here's the thing
here's the thing though i feel like the
only way possible
that microsoft can arm strong them all
they want but at the end of the day i
feel like the only way playstation will
agree to it is that they're like this is
the last xbox game like we we can't be
competing if you want to be a software
and have game passes
shut your flaps off microsoft
microsoft wants to be a software service
company
king literally just said that it doesn't
make sense
well both of them want to be but i feel
like only one company right now asks the
actual listen they both wrote back to
lose the overhead and the barriers that
is created by consoles that that whole
thing is up is a complete barrier to be
honest with you some people won't ever
purchase a console but if there's an app
on your television you just have a
controller and you just pull up and play
um that changes everything yeah but kick
some people don't worry about that
either
there's going to be a group of people
whatever right just like it wasn't yeah
it's not accepted right now just like
you talking about down the road
just like at the beginning of last
generation it wasn't accepted for online
structure games and now it's it's mildly
accepted everywhere i'm not talking
about tomorrow
no these dudes when i say there's no um
no more places they're not gonna shut
down playstation tomorrow king it won't
be no playstation 6
station 6 tomorrow anyway so what are
you talking about i'm talk this
generation this generation that we're in
right now has been stagnated because of
this covet and has been stagnated
because of the lack of um
silicone right so we're actually three
years behind to be honest with you when
everything really gets uh you know up
and going you don't have
um
the libraries aren't just made for this
current gen they're made for this gen
and pathogen it's cross-gen
right now for at least until next year
right
let's just say that part so
going forward this is this actually this
cove stuff has
elongated this generation i think it
gave it three more years than it
normally that five-year cadence into
another console so many people don't
even have it yeah but i think this these
cpus and stuff like that i think we have
uh the outlier again of the 360 and the
playstation 3 generation that lasted
eight to nine years and it was so long
but what technology are we looking at at
that point in time when we reached that
part because we're at 5g right now
remember
we were at 2g before we were at 1g
before so
what what g will be at then what what
type of uh
will we interact with our gaming systems
because dudes was uh adverse to digital
a minute ago you know they're shipping
consoles right now with no we're no
driving no driving
keep in mind i know like people think
it's going to take like 10 years for
like like internet services like 5g to
get like you got companies like dish
network investing millions to get to get
that infrastructure where they can
provide a 5g internet service
yeah i honestly believe that it's going
to be
we we're going to see the rise of the
little ruku consoles
and um people's going to be palatable
for uh 1080p 60 frames per second 1080p
120 something frames per second and and
and or 1440p 60 frames per second 1440p
120 frames per second and then it's
going to be those console dudes that
actually want the the robust hardware
like a series s
or s or a playstation 5 to have that
right there but we're going to see the
rise of those little
uh type uh consoles
and that price if they hit the 199
or or or even less like 100 and you can
actually pick this stuff up and just go
play it changes how we look at stuff you
know and we no longer are in that space
this is the space that they want to be
in right
and it's not really anything to do with
the gamers because
at what point in time do we dictate
exactly what do they do we don't
they dictate what they how the game goes
oh yeah yeah for sure all right let's
get solved when we move on but yeah this
is just it's just interesting i think it
says
it's a we're in
for 2022 to start off the way it is and
we're two months in
buckle up like we we're illegitimately
in a section where the industry's
changing yeah we're living here we're
living in a time
where
there's really a shift going on and i'm
just holding on you wake up you don't
know what's about to happen we hear the
rumors of of what you're doing or saying
microsoft activation yeah more rumors we
i i'm acquisitions i'm hearing more big
stuff that's already done and it's just
it's a crazy time we got to see what's
going to happen let's all finish out and
get super chats we move on no no i think
i mean all of y'all making great points
like it's just it it just feels like
you know this could have even been
reacted like i have my theories about
their plans all the way all along right
right but at the same time when you see
it could very easily have been a big
shock that the bungie deal with sony you
know made microsoft kind of jaw dropped
to the floor when they said the games
are going to be moving forward right
that's the thing you expect
but to say like hey now we're on this
train where all these games are going to
be for
you know for playstation gamers
i'm sure your jaw dropped like what what
do you mean like this is not something
you ever expected from the playstation
and they have been the ones that have
been moped besides nintendo they've been
the ones most resistant to change
um
but i you know i honestly do feel that
call of duty is on that level that you
know
you know fortnite made them bend the
knee in a lot of ways
the call of duty is one of those things
that you know when you think about the
money that comes in on on on all fronts
for that
it's a beast like you have to
it's smart business to make sure that
game is everywhere and everything else
again
when you start talking about all these
you know when you talk about how people
are are thinking about overwatch too and
and the fact that they don't think they
should be in overwatch to just add it to
overwatch one when if you're putting
these games out you want goodwill around
them that means you want big communities
around them it only makes sense that you
would put them in as many places as
possible so again like we just said the
industry is changing right before our
eyes in a way we i don't think we ever
expected i think
we thought game pass was going to change
the way in in the way we consume games
and the way we were sold games whatever
the case may be i don't think any of us
really expected this level of shift
happening
so quickly so i mean
we're going to be talking about this for
a long time but history is happening
unfortunately we're in the middle of it
as it's happening
yeah and and honestly the game industry
is going to look different in five six
years it just is absolutely microsoft
going on everything
and that's what we got let's move on
unprecedented time they're gonna they're
gonna
they're gonna change the name of xbox to
the only box
just vamp for a couple of years
crazy times going on i see the chair i'm
[Laughter]
from desire to continue cod's still
going exclusive
is on that king trade all right okay
then we got the brightest sun with the
10 euro super chat microsoft would not
have the incentive to would not have the
incentive to cease or limit making
xenomax games available for purchase on
rival consoles that was written in
zenimax deal conclusion in the european
official documents they would not have
the incentive to see so limit but they
start feeling unless they change
starfield let's see
exactly um we have lord starkiller xbox
series xl1 member for five months thank
you sir big win for game pass because
cod will be available day date uh day
and it's true anything you know anything
they own the incentive will be to get it
on game pass because yeah you're gonna
have it there for quote unquote free or
no extra money um then we have mr mdj
five dollars which activision has to ask
permission to go out in the streets
bungie can just throw up the deuces to
playstation and say bye bye felicia
so what we're saying is activision is
like the locked-in wife they can't go
anywhere
which and and this is this is why i
didn't understand them using that
specific clip of king
for this argument because it was
[ __ ] because it because the argument
is the argument the argument was that
sony somehow i mean bungie somehow
managed to finagle this deal whereas
like if activision is for the streets
it's because microsoft desires it to be
whereas whereas bungie being for the
streets is bunty telling sony where
would it be
so what you're saying what you're saying
is is microsoft is very open to having
open relationships
it was made to have one whether it's
whereas the microsoft it is the pimp
move you go out to the streets
of the streets
what i don't understand
right and and this is the this is the
issue that i have fundamentally with the
with the busted brains that i feel that
a lot of these dudes
said
everything we do is out here
you understand what i'm saying like and
then
microsoft says
you know and i and i always got to do
that the under duress right now the
police is watching uh uh huh you know
keep your hands on the on the dashboard
[Laughter]
we know you're slick with them fingers
and then like yeah man i said call of
duty could go hang out man what's up
y'all know man i'm not gonna lock him
down like that he could hang with his
friends
dudes yeah let warzone out keep the
other one in the house like so it's it's
it's these little
favorites
where they say yeah
it's going to be available
yeah but
in their whole entirety
of anything that we got coming out it's
for the streets so
what what is the sense right who made
out in this deal death that's so when
you use that clip
you're using that clip to the detriment
of yourself yeah because you have to
honestly the wrong clip for what they're
trying to get right at you for it like
why would you use that but i understood
this part when cog used that clip it was
genius
and people saw how much traction that it
was getting and you wanted to associate
yourself with something that was
credible and every person that decided
to
use that to talk about getting knees or
something goofy about it all you did was
just play yourself you fell in the cogs
trap yeah i didn't look at the context
of what it was
it just sounded good
that's why so i'm about receipts
yeah like i honestly believe they will
pick and choose what they will let out
the door
right
and
they say yo you know this game of
service you can have that um this game
of service you can have what bring back
the most bread with these dude what they
like over there yeah you can hear that
oh there's new stuff down that's mine
that's mine i can't let that out yeah
here's a question i do have for you guys
like
we brought it like a little bit last
week
do you think that since activision's
games will be everywhere for right now
we don't know like we can only go where
we're going but
that is
tony hawk i don't think i don't think if
they make another tony hawk i don't make
another crash like that's not going
everywhere new one okay i don't think so
so they did say popular but do you think
that because last year last week we were
saying that you know maybe some of the
other playstation studios would fill a
way that their games can't be everywhere
but bungie is
so do you think that could we could see
something similar with no yo we got 30
some studios but why is activision get
to run wild listen like i said
there are no rules
i
this
i swear it's like a brain fart and it it
it's just i don't honestly get it if
they said one or two titles is gonna go
there that's not the entirety of your
future catalog like
but all they had to do was open the door
and i can go right
this is the this is the seed that starts
the one console future watch
all of this wow i am so i am so beyond
this if one person said everything i do
is out here son everything there's no
question right
they just want to associate something
else with that same narrative oh your
activision is doing the same no they're
not
they're not doing that and it's going to
be titles that don't go across the
street no i agree with that before i
agree bungie titles will be across the
street up the block and down the corner
look we got to see what's going to
happen man it is interesting times
i'm happy that it is though
i hope it's in spartacus make me buy
exactly
flame two dollars which i
quote phil's a nice guy just corded in
2025
shout out to jazz just got it right just
get it right salute
there we go creeper evox five dollar
super chat sony be pretty woman dealing
with bungie for attention pretty woman
paying paying for attention everybody
pays for attention
if you have bungie without the bungee
employees you don't have bungee like
yeah something there's a provision in
there they can't go
sit down they're all millionaires though
that's for sure that's right rich as
hell see mad five dollars a chat the
question in the end is what's the cost
to other platforms from microsoft's
properties games will be exclusive to
game pass not xbox
no
no i don't know about that we make one
day get a game that's exclusive to game
pass but i don't know
we'll see
and we got michael need niziela nedila i
apologize if i wrecked that five dollar
super chat we knew the microsoft that
microsoft has contractual obligations
from the next two to three years for cod
how do you think the gaming industry
will change by then
i just think you're gonna start you're
gonna start seeing more cooperation
specifically between they have to go
playstation and xbox when it comes to
these games that require a community
around them i just think i think that's
gonna be a lot of nice players gotta
work with each other yeah when it comes
to cross play and cross-progression
we're seeing in mlb the show this year
like all that stuff is going to become
the norm i think and plus it would look
really bad on microsoft if they snatch
call of duty off the platform yeah when
they've one of the biggest people on
doing cross platform and progression if
there was no game pass right and michael
let's say we came into this generation
right let's say there was no game pass
and microsoft just
but they did get the support of
microsoft the way that they had it in
the past right and they had all this
money to spend
if if the status quo had not changed
because of game pass then yes everything
that you see them by would probably be
exclusive
game pass is is what kind of changes the
conversation all around it so in a way
if they wanted to dominate in that same
way that sony has dominated whatever
they kind of shot themselves with a
football game pass if you see what i'm
going at like yeah they change the
conversation so that they can't really
do it anymore but yeah whatever
um let me see
heart
if you read the language they said they
will continue to sell as in you have the
current games will continue to sell them
to you new ones is on gamepads
we'll see i mean this is gonna be so
hilarious and and when i'm walking
around with a bag of knees
i just look up and say hey addy i got
your knees back
yeah
then we got um
lord starkey let's 10 dollar super chat
it's okay if cod is multi-plat that
creates a real good revenue stream for
microsoft sony supporters will pay 70
dollars while cod will be included in
game pass day of date big win for
microsoft xbox yes that is for sure if
you have gay pass
if you have game pass or that will be in
there already then we have dragon heart
yobe 10 should be chat if i'm wrong in
this i will get my knees sculpted there
will be an event and the ilp will be the
guests of said gaming event or they will
be the headliners mark my words peace
it's funny you said that it's funny he
said that right
stuff going on and stuff going on
yeah we gotta talk about that yeah we'll
talk about that
we got laura starkiller again five
thousand chat microsoft was reading the
room when it came to the ftc better to
keep multi-plat versus jeopardizing the
activision blizzard acquisition
it's absolutely not worth
losing
you know the whole thing
over call of duty bro to be honest but i
think the namesake king is the in my
opinion one of the biggest parts of this
deal that people oh gamers don't care
about it but that mobile
i get that i get that because when you
look at amount of studios it doesn't
compare right
but king
you can't let that go listen when they
cop i was like let me try this candy
crush
i haven't spent a dollar on it which is
great
but yeah the grind is incredible it's
crazy and we know they want in there and
they're streaming it's so much to this
but yeah guys
yeah graham c five dollar super chat and
king's defense regulatory agencies fail
to do research all the time okay
they're gonna do research on this one
and also we gotta remember we didn't we
don't usually get political but you know
there could be a situation where someone
wants to make an example
out of microsoft that they're doing too
much i want to know who's out there
who's this strong cry babies pointing
stuff out hey you want nobody snitching
this no no no
who got the six nine faces
there there are agendas apparently the
agenda says microsoft has been attacked
microsoft certain acquisitions they've
made in the past have come under
scrutiny
you've gotten through and so
somebody
with revenge on revenge influence
politics you gotta play that and the
last thing is shout out to pictures of g
i think he said it too is that we didn't
mention enough but a lot of this is
access to this apps and this future
because that's the department that made
the statement like we didn't like it
wasn't like phil spencer and xbox gaming
and like it was this app
this is access for the future and future
plans and they're worried about legal
and regulation
going in a direction that may go so
they're like yo we are full transparent
here what we're trying to do because
what we're doing is going to be
ultimately better for developers and
everyone and it goes against kind of
what apple was trying to do with things
yeah it's a lot going on here they're
trying to make themselves look like the
ultimate ultimate good guy look what
they're doing but look what we're doing
so that if you let these laws that's
about to come up that could change the
game we on the right side of history
that's why they're calling out companies
that have nothing to do with doing it
you calling up because they like yo okay
okay i see what you're doing next okay i
see you okay okay now you're throwing us
to the statement okay
yeah yeah
it's funny but i mean they gotta do what
they gotta do gotta do together what's
funny he's like three or four years from
now not one of those games goes to
switch
it was our desire
king will get us though king will get us
if that happens
i told you
it's a call of duty 2025 and they don't
got a playstation logo order at the
bottom of the trailer we are going to
get it
it's going to be profits
videos in the car you already know i'm
having a lot of people on
i can't
all right then we got the rubber knob
five dollars
morning lords all platforms can have
call of duty they just need to put game
pass on their system first yep phil said
that moving that route
but bingo five dollars of attack would
be cool to acquire would be cool to
acquire all of wb's last time warner
discovery next to 2023 and make those ip
based shows themselves it would
complement xbox game pass they are not
in a position to make any kind of show
themselves they're not i mean that's
just not there they're going to let
someone else do it yeah
then we got lord starkiller five dollars
which lord cognito i had it wrong also
but it is better for microsoft to make
some concessions to the ftc yeah versus
putting the uh a b acquisition at risk
that is true but maybe the fec like uh
christopher hart said
what is that what is that
the f.e.c
okay
moving on top
there we go
and we got chaos smite five dollars of
attack with phil getting the lifetime
achievement awards he should be knighted
and add sir in front of his name sir
phil
hello we talk about two different types
of knights and two different types of uh
then we got ty uh tai tai casares uh 31
super chat sony be yelling across the
street at gta 6 saying come get this
wallet gta 6 is like i see big bank
though
all of you iron lords are the best you
make my monday mornings down under worth
wow thank you sir yep it is monday over
there thank you for getting it thank you
man
we got tired
on valentine's day and look at me in my
valentine's day jacket
[Laughter]
once again with the eight australian
dollar super chat with all of these
games that xbox now has do you all think
xbox will increase game pass or make
similar options like a five dollar deal
for for uh
fps or five dollars for rpgs
no i mean at some point i'll just raise
it they'll just raise it at some point
yeah
i'm gonna be honest i never liked the 50
i would have wished they would have just
gone to 20 immediately this sounds
stupid but like 20 is like a nice round
number like no i like the 15.
my ocd doesn't like it when it leaves my
account like that
good to see
that was that was the sony thing you
know i'd rather pay 70 dollars
we already did get a game pass exclusive
game it was the space jam beat em okay
only people game pass could download and
play
no do not remember that one hollywood
rules five dollars which i think the
anger within the xbox community is that
we know sony wouldn't have shared cod
and microsoft uh and microsoft had them
by the short and curly by the shortened
curlies and let them off
uh
it's just too much money lisa's watching
sorry brother keep it moving nothing see
you here
then we got lord metroid two thousand
chat sony microsoft the rivals not a
couple compete yeah
game is changing
i don't think there's no competition
then we got mandingo
big dollar super chat yo it's super bowl
sunday homegrown cincinnati fan here can
hoodie nation get a nod from the iop
yeah
and remember fellas keep it thick
who they say they're gonna beat them
bangles
then we got hollywood rules five dollars
for the chat the xbox community wanted
phil to snatch cod from sony like the
soup nazi and seinfeld no cod for you
come back in ten years
stupid that's how i feel
all right then we gotta make sure i
didn't jump
nope we're good we're good to go we're
covered yeah all right cool let's get
into it attic you up
your favorite
platinum games
you love smile and bubble when you hear
that so
platinum games was on uh twitter earlier
this week and they were saying that they
they were kind of hitting you you say it
right what type of fine then you set it
up no what's the name of that platform
that you you always say with the right
thing the twitter the twitter supposed
to say
okay whatever it's twitter
they were saying that they kind of
regret what happened with
uh scale bound and they actually said
believe it or not
they actually said that
they would love to be able to correct
that and they apologize to the community
to microsoft so that they uh that they
uh that they put too much they put a lot
of trust in them as a as a partner and
they apologize for letting them down and
so it put up a lot of you know thought
process of what's going on over there
and i wanted to bring it to the realm
and you know
first off i want to you know
ask every lord what your thoughts when
you first saw this are and uh you know
go from there
stop
i want to hear something so first yeah
ah
okay oh the other side
listen
when i saw
scale bound i was like okay
it's fine like it's i the idea of uh you
know respect
uh
i like that i love dragons i love you
wait wait you were there with me that
year in e3 right oh yeah you sold with
me yes okay all right thank you yeah
thank you let them know please i thought
okay it i i thought it was ambitious
right there was a lot of stuff going on
on screen frame rate looked terrible at
the time the frame rate was broken
um but
it looked generic in the way that you
know i don't know the appeal of a
character that's wearing a headset
like i just don't i just didn't like the
combat look cool they were aspect but
that the aspects of it that didn't seem
cool
made it feel like people were going to
start reacting to it like the way they
did with um
what the hell was it was it godfall
the playstation launch game where it's
like yeah it just it just looked god
same same me and kind of generic
poor god awful i know
but for me
it didn't it didn't have that flair that
i expect from platinum games
so
you know i think a long time ago on a
podcast i was like yeah a prediction
they bring back scale bound and it's a
panda dragon game that's the only way
you're gonna bring back
i just
i don't think it's happening and it's
probably not a good practice to um shout
out to vin diesel
you don't call somebody out
and say hey we want to do this when
they've made it clear that they don't
want to do this because
ben did the same thing to the rock when
he was like we need you to come back for
the end of fast and furious and the rock
was like i told you
i ain't coming back to the face of the
period like
like don't try to shame me in front of
everybody
to try to get a reaction so for me yeah
but phil's a nice guy that's a nice guy
but you you've noticed that there's been
no response to this
so i i don't think i think it's the good
steps made to sort of if they're if that
relationship needs repairing in some way
or whatever for them to work together
exclusively i can see that happening i
don't think it's scalebound coming back
um
it has to be something else in my heart
breaking my heart
that's what i got i need i'm
done well when i saw the game i was like
uh this was a
unmitigated mess
you know the only thing that looks good
was the cut scenes
uh they were they had enemies coming out
of these little huts
it was
it was inside the weirdest places
it looked so
uh
early last gen it looked 360 ish but the
fact that it had like a dragon in it it
just
it it wasn't it and everybody keeps
talking about the scale bound like it
was some forgotten warrior that was
gonna be great no phil saw a 60 mega
critic it was like i'm not doing that
i'm just sick and tired of these games
not living up to expectations now what i
do say is
uh platinum saw
all this money being spread around
you know uh
bungie 3.6 billion
68 billion excuse me microsoft i do
apologize for what we did in the past
and i think that we can rectify
something and we work good together
microsoft
let me get one more chance please baby
like that's all i saw and
i can see honestly
they can use unreal engine 5
uh
and they can actually
uh
get a really good looking game uh with
with time effort and money
i do believe in dell's get a second
chance
but with the stigma that's attached to
this game and the level of scrutiny
that's uh attached to this game any game
with this name
has to be a 90 plus on a metacritic
score right so why put that level
of uh
pressure
on a developer in in this sense and and
also this this this there's a rumor
going around which is not true microsoft
has a game that's just like scalebound
and development no they don't um you
talking about the monster hunter type
game yeah that's it's not scale bound
right
what what microsoft wanted from scale
bound is they wanted uh a co-op dragon
type of game or whatever what platinum
was making was probably a single uh type
of uh player game and then they bolted
on the multiplayer to it and it just
didn't go right it just didn't look
right it looked like a game out of sync
it was like too many chefs in in the pot
it didn't look right so let the game die
and and if
it
and you know what and if phil looks at
it and he said a lot of things he had to
make cold calls on stuff that was put in
production before him
stuff that didn't look good so i know
people saying but crackdown made it out
man how the hell crackdown got out there
but my scale but you don't even know
about my scale by my spellbound
like
beloved franchise scalebound i know like
your scale barrel was gonna be the one
my g crack down
like you talking about an established
franchise i don't care what that is to a
ip that they didn't need to sink any
more money in and he knew it was going
to be bad from the rip
let it go
so maybe they could work with them and
do something else i mean i i like some
of the games that transformers games and
eternal games i like absolutely
astral chain is a banger tell me tell me
that the dude from scale bound didn't
look like nero yeah you look like dante
i agree right i would solve on that too
i feel like come on come on
i mean it's a lot of disrespect for my
platinum but no i like platinum games
it's cool but i hear what y'all say i
mean it's not you're not out of pocket i
feel i i just feel like yeah they got
this history you know we talked you know
how i feel about actual change that uh
they got the what is it the metal gear
rising vengeance and yeah tom and i like
they've got a resume i like transformers
devastation i don't care nobody said i
like that joy they had the real actors
they had peter cullen frank walker it
was a cartoon anime i was in there
construct the clowns it was a goat
i didn't care what was going on but um
look
does this sound a little bit of
desperation yes
and and the reason why i've never seen
comedy sound like this like i've never
seen him
you know but you know like like that
like he doesn't seem like that person
down i mean we are very fortunate at
lawrencegaming.net to interview meet him
in person meet another son in person
interview them about the one-on-one on
onlinegaming.net make sure you check
that out if something is up there check
that out and and the videos also on our
last podcast in the exclusive interviews
we have that with platinum games not
many people can say that i had to flip
yeah yeah nobody else has had the
flashlight
so i'm always
it's a cough that happens
in that interview
the cough that is heard
[Music]
yes i am biased i love platinum so
here's the thing
i have to agree with king and solve on
this though like it does scream a little
bit desperation in the sense that like
the fact that you go in public
to me this could have been a call behind
the scene
right this could have been a call like
the relationships is there so it almost
feels to me like
one person is not picking up the phone
or not interested
you know what i'm saying so here's my
thing like
you stupid
like i don't there's so much rumors of
speculation would go down
with scale down like i don't know like
one here you think that one thing we
heard is that platinum was not familiar
with unreal engine at the time right
right and that you know this was too
much of an untaken they may have been
this other thing then we hear another
rumors that microsoft wouldn't co-op on
it and that'd be the scope would have
been too big then we got to be real
we're clowning the frame rate and all
that but that was oh g xbox one
connects xbox one
you know what i'm saying so again i i
this is what i look at it
this game has to be important to call me
a song for him to do this like this guy
because what i hear it's his dream game
like this is the game he's always wanted
to make to king's point i do agree
you know people see microsoft throw a
lot of money around
myself acquiring you know for him to
publicly like yo phil let's get in the
lab let's just
say let's work let's collab like yo
that's that's a big deal so the thing is
this is what i say you know if is a bad
look if a game gets canceled let's call
that right clearly something was going
on maybe they was doing too much
projects who knows i wasn't in the room
but what i would say is like
i think it's a gs move for him to put a
little bit of public pressure on
microsoft to say
look the fans want it they come on phil
you'll say god think so if the
relationship is fractured then all i
would hope is that
they give them the rights to make the
game even if it's multi-plat and they go
okay we'll give you the rights back
we'll give you you know we'll work out
the gate negotiate and then it'll be
maybe like a game pass deal we get the
first or we get a time pretty much like
we're not going to pay for it right let
you
give you the right to have someone else
right in fairness to microsoft addict if
they were upset and they saw you know
when you come home your kids didn't do
the homework for whatever reason
right you don't work at all
the last thing about is like yo we gonna
make a deal again and we're gonna work
again because you got to trust that
person again to do the homework as it
was assigned so i understand from a
business standpoint i can't get as much
as a gamer fan i want scaled mountain to
come back to see what it could be i
could understand them like now fam we
did that right so we're going to do this
if you want the deal so bad either money
exchange or whatever you could have the
rights back we ain't gonna be foul
because i think that's the right thing
because
clearly microsoft ain't doing nothing
with scalebound they don't seem at least
for what we see it doesn't appear
apparently last year they renewed it
right so if they renew it or whatever or
you just get back in the lab and say yo
let's do this let's do this track right
quick you know what i'm saying either
way i think it would be a good look
you do that j right quick you know so my
thing is
pull up they need these type of games
we could clown platinum you could say
they overrated microsoft need you got a
japanese dude y'all we want to work with
you that's what they need we sit there
saying like get them in pocket get them
in you don't got to buy them but be nice
but even if the trucks get the trust
popping
honest with you
i feel like the only way microsoft would
do it is that they were bought
well they got to provide value well it
would be like one of those things where
it's like we value the products you put
out might not have been scalebound
uh but the only way we gonna fund
scalebound is if you sell your whole
company
you know what i like that yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna listen now
but
but the thing i want selfishly when it
regales to happen take that catalog give
me astral chain give me action chain two
give me all the games that you made over
here that's what i want i know it's
probably unrealistic but that's what i
want
i mean when it comes to me this is how
i'm shaking kid
this is when it comes to me i feel
like
if it was strictly
a mismanagement thing
and there's not too much
bad blood there if it's salvageable to
fix that bad blood
let's just get scalebound out like
imagine it's like i said imagine i don't
care about skeleton let me put that out
right now i don't care about scale but
imagine being at an e3 and they ended
with a vague trailer and it's a skeleton
and they got that series x
flavor 28. i feel you but if that game
comes out and it's a seven it's an l
right though i don't think if if this is
if this is greenlit again
i hi
we microsoft's always like you know we
left them do what they do they ain't
letting planet no he can't let them
because the kids mess up the homework
you can't you can't fly they're gonna
have that video like microsoft gonna
have matt booty over there living over
there
he could come out of the head office and
rub in his eyes what's we doing today or
you say look that's nice that you would
like to work with us to get that that's
the as king was safe that part's over
and king would be like what you can do
this is a classic king where you don't
want to work with you what we can do is
you can make that yourself
and then
you know when it's finished we'll decide
if we want to include this on our system
on any game pass deal or whatever
whatever and we can work on that then
maybe we get some rights together like i
just see that
i don't see them trying to yank astral
traffic yeah get that after change
please
yank
that microsoft keeps renewing that
scalebound one is because
they know it means a lot to them so
then i feel like
they might see because because they keep
in mind these companies renew yeah uh
copyrights all the time like every year
every single year uh but to me
do you guys see any relevance to keeping
the scale about ip
a lot of stuff that they never do
anything with it and it could be nothing
but yeah to me it really feels like look
we do
look into japan a lot right and we got
that scalebound ip we know he likes that
thing yeah so part of me feels like
microsoft i've got his baby hostage yeah
no no tell me that what it feels like
it's like it's like if they ever go into
that if they ever have a a negotiations
with platinum about buying them or
something because like regardless how
scalebound turned out and it's
regardless how i feel about this
but regardless how i feel about the
studio we can't deny the quality of
games that does come out of that studio
so it's just like if microsoft ever
decided one day they wake up you know
they get they they ate some bacon and
eggs and then they're like i'm gonna go
buy platinum games
they started that conversation
the opening conver the opening sentence
would be we'll fund the rest is
scalebound
as long as you sell your company because
we need to type the game
what is going on well here's the thing i
i honestly feel what that
this isn't strategic to get scalebound i
really feel like this is
the ultimate play for them to bend the
knee to body card
no no this
this is
them trying to establish relations with
them again yes get a game out and then
after they see
like you know how they they gave sony
the hit they gave us
this is going to be one of those words
they're going to make sure to give
microsoft the hit right and then
afterwards he'll be like yo yo phil how
are you feeling about that game
okay
i mean it's not unprecedented
with hitman right
it's like they they sitting there with
the radio up and they me in the middle
of the mall like microsoft here my song
like what happens
serenading them like
on this baby microsoft no
what happened to skeletons
if they renegotiate and scale down comes
back but it's a different game it's no
co-op experience it's the game he
originally wanted and he got through let
me make his game but let him name it
himself
you know what it is you can't scale
balance scale bound sounds like the cool
name you don't want to just give up that
name
do that with it no we gotta we gotta
film
i don't you didn't care about that scale
about like i did like either one of us
did you can't say that they in the e3
show with that that ain't gonna blow the
internet bro it would blow there today
come on kkk don't go back into that
relationship
two things that microsoft can do that i
know for a fact to blow up the internet
one a scale bound revival and two are
right son of rome too yup and a bear
both of those in it
yeah those days
those of me
i know one thing i don't want what
i don't want them going back to that
lady that can't cook leaves
that's another thing we have to take she
can't cook for you she can cook for the
new people she can't cook for nobody
because she he said yo so we can't act
like astro che wasn't a hit listen
microsoft said what you said baby what
you want for breakfast i want some bacon
eggs and cheese he said cool bacon eggs
and cheese and came back with salami
sausage among people
that's not what i asked for
what you do what you do king is
you're like yo you know what i i didn't
know i wanted this tone now and you yeah
yeah but
when you got your mouth fixed for what
you wanted fixed for and then bring you
the wrong thing i was saying that the
pizza and you don't kind of like it and
it's pepperoni on the pizza you won't
kill somebody
kind of like how your taste buds was
fixed for activision games only on xbox
but it turns out
i will say there's no way you talk about
comedy sad in 2024
i gotta say this about comedy platinum
games there is distinctive there is
distinctively
an a team and a b team yes
oh yeah
for sure
i don't think xbox has been has had one
game by the 18t and that's the thing
that's the thing i'm gonna read this uh
donald truck who's a super chat fighter
chat it's the last one that came in but
i'll just jump he says y'all ain't
getting astral chain anywhere because
the switch that's the switch ip right
also kami has never missed let that man
cook and and that is kind of true when
you look at the games kami has worked on
near automata
um bayonetta astral change
um
like the the hits
remember vanquish
yes
oh yeah so oh it is
it is fair to say that this kind of was
the first time that he slipped up like
that yeah that he just couldn't get a
product to where it needed to be
just one
yo don't you do that don't you do that
don't you do i mean
you implying that his skills have
deteriorated
he was dancing in the mirror by himself
and then he found out he really wasn't
jiggy like dude
back in the morning
i'm just saying let's go have fun
the stuff the stuff that he has dropped
i would say yes it warrants giving him a
chance i just don't think it's scary wow
like i i mean listen
you made near automata like and for a
while near tom but it was playstation
exclusive and pc interviews i believe
like he needs
something on that level give me
something on there what's
they've been making games without other
people right
i'm just keeping them right right right
why do you need my help
why do you need these bedfellows
and then bring it don't talk to me about
what but why are they gonna make the
game and you ain't gonna give no
experience you know thing uh uh what's
the worst this is the sign of your faith
because this the last time you don't
give your money you came back with that
so what if they have an agreement they
just make an agreement well i don't know
how i'm contracting we have to get hold
here
because you ain't doing that with the
dave you hold it on your name you're
never going to make a scale better i
agree with king there though right i
don't know this obviously i don't know
this works this way i don't know how
this works you really want to make this
game so badly made the game with no game
no name with no name come to microsoft
be like this is our vision for what's
capable of supposed to be but don't they
there's a banger but this works together
but don't isn't it bigger than the name
y'all chat if y'all know isn't it just
the name the prop don't they should have
all the assets and everything yeah
microsoft got the assets don't they got
all of those so whatever news if that is
the case if you really want to make that
game
listen but this is the thing
this is what gets me though this why are
you holding on to the bars you holding
on to the
with okay it's okay but let's let's open
this let me get this
dream game right it's the game about the
dude with the sony wall that's his dream
he said it though
you don't feel it but you don't like it
but that's what he said he said he
wanted to spit like dies
here's the thing though here's the thing
i'm not gonna say
that that wasn't his dream game i don't
know what was going on at platinum's at
that time they were working on a lot of
games we don't know what kind of
financial things are they had to
probably split their studio to do that
financial
responsibility all i'm saying is if
there is a realm of possibility where
they highly supervise platinum games
making scale bound
and they actually yeah i know highly
supervised they're gonna be in jail okay
they're
they're gonna rent out like a whole
hotel and make them all go there and not
let them leave but a joke
it's the thing
if it's will if both participants are
willing to do this what's the harm
they spend 60 billion on activision and
you can't
they can't they can't do it with with
platinum just for your vision
understands the assignment
but you big money bag microsoft you
don't need what you hold it on to it
why are you suggesting
you guys keep saying over and over again
they should make the game and then go to
microsoft they literally own the game
you can't just can't they can't make
something
come up with your oh listen you you like
make another hole
make your own
you know what they do they make the
exact same game
but
instead of the dude with the beats you
get an avatar of king and that's the
whole game until it's converged you can
make the same deal with the beats just
use your own assets
and if you love that baby so much you
wouldn't have sold them out the gate
anywhere
here's the thing here's the thing
the way i was described to it the reason
that we told y'all we've never used
proteins before
you try to force these pro tools on the
reason that
the way i interpret it i don't know if
anyone uh you know correct me i got you
platinum i got this the reason that they
went to the engine they was is because
the requirements and the stuff microsoft
wanted you had to have that engine out
here try to putting them whack rizzo
beats on us and we don't make them beats
like that
if i'm wrong
but if if platinum games i and i've been
very vulnerable about making fun of them
on
they'll get one hit and like six misses
but when that one hit hits and it's
usually for a platform they make a
platform game it's usually a huge hit
when they make multi-plats usually it's
when it's a little bit like i said
explain to me the 18. but but look look
explain to me how they hit hits on every
other platform but when microsoft shows
up and says they want co-op experience
they want this they want that they miss
that so the only i don't understand the
assignment but then white but my point
is is
we can't act like microsoft didn't try
to push that on them we don't know if
it's something they're not doing then
why are we blaming just platinum a
little bit of that
guys in the microsoft ain't looking
because shout out to sharif baxter he
said i don't call getting clown arizona
but rayquan was mad when he brought the
violins on that whack on that that whack
album and rayquan said and then rayquan
left and made wu-tang versus shaolin
that's what he did i'm insane i'm not
saying that they need to they let's
let's clarify that now microsoft does
not need skeletons by any means
but
well dude man that would look so good
like there are some things that's
happened in the in the xbox one
generation
that
that scale bound coming back uh scale
bell coming back a uh a rise subtle room
two you corrected the majority of the
generation when it comes to their
misfire no why why
why is this game so important to people
it's not import
well look first off we can't act like
microsoft has a ton of japanese support
thank you okay so that part right there
that you're saying you want them to
purchase a japanese studio that has a
pedigree of making a bunch of misses and
hits here and there
okay okay we we've got i'm about to i'm
about to bring up the metacritic score
on all their games anyway moving on like
i said at the end of the day we'll see
what happens it's very interesting i
will say that um
i just hope that platinum is not in
trouble you know what i'm saying because
sometimes you're going to see it like
you've gotta
to the chat that's mad at me about reza
yes rizza is one of the goats i get it
but we're not going to act like every
album when every wu tang beat when he
went
digital
yeah so come on now my hip-hop heads i
see y'all y'all know i got respect for
the for the legend i'm just saying so
everything the legend and even his own
something right clan members didn't
agree with a lot of stuff later on
that's here here here it is
uh bayonetta 2 92. near automotive 91
bayonetta a90 uh uh let me go down uh
astro train 87. the wonderful 101. 85.
uh-huh it's getting lower
what's next
oh we can't keep going yeah
83 like but my point is is they make
quality games let's get to the bottom of
the tree
i mean we could do do do you want to do
that with all the xbox studios
you want to do that with all the xbox
studios because that's not going to work
out for you i just said scale balance is
zero and you can't before a game that
should not it did somebody saw it and
said no it does it does it says here on
here
scalebound to be uh to be announced and
this is canceled
no platinum misses when they make
somebody else's vision legend of korra
tmnt etc those aren't those aren't their
games those are their properties they
are their games they make those games
they aren't their properties
and and again that was the b team
but you got to consider too that that
was the budget that was a lot of them as
well like it's not like it's not like i
think it was activision or ea i don't
know who owns the legend of court it's
not like they handed them a two hundred
dollar million budget and said make me
legend accord like
we good let's get this ball
all right so let's beat that's pretty
super chat oh let me see
cipher pole 192 five pound super chat
microsoft tell the playstation don't get
future games it's like telling your side
chick you'll leave your girl we know
it's cat but she believes it anyway
there we go hard to need two dollars
phil should tell platinum to take a hike
jesus
he said nothing he returned to nothing
at the end of the day we don't know what
happened between the two companies we
just don't know what's not happening
somebody retweeting and liking it
there we go
playstation uh playstation copying xbox
one feature snap we have activity cards
snap help we have game help xbox voice
commands we have ps voice commands okay
are you talking about hey playstation
we're about to get into it hey
there we got lucious augustus two
dollars let me chat let's give scale
bound to ninja theory
that sounds like that's the ultimate
smacking effect oh that's kind of funny
but yeah that's disrespectful but
yeah yeah
then we got urban ninja member for three
months thank you sir these purchases are
being coordinated by microsoft and sony
to keep amazon attention and facebook
out yes and we've talked about that as
well yeah keep them out of there
um then we got lord starkiller five
dollars for chat if microsoft ever wants
to revive scalebound let playground
games do do they do the depth platinum
is not worth microsoft's effort jesus
told you i think
keep the a team not to beat him mr two
opinionated five dollars which had i'm
sorry um but in my opinion in my opinion
no western studio can match platinum's
combat or style so you either let
platinum or the dmc 5 team finish it or
let it stay dead all right opinions
let it flow
down here don't know
five dollars super chat they need tango
to co-develop the game to oversee them
i can see that i know i can really see
that happening why they're gonna need
oversight because obviously you know if
something if if this did happen
there has to be some kind of oversight
because there was damage to the to the
right
there was damage in their relationship
in the past there has to be some form of
like this check
and you can't leave them you can't leave
them alone with that you gotta put an
[Laughter]
it is funny but it's true like they
would have to have some kind of why i
highly doubt microsoft would feel
comfortable working with them again if
they didn't have some form of oversight
yeah until there was a relationship
rebuilt i gotta retrace do you go into
knowing that you gotta monitor their
phones for me they still they still they
still have some form of relationship
they've still worked with them to bring
near to to game pass like they still
talk to them yo hold on
platinum games thought they was about to
bear but turned out to be met the bed
without his facial hair i hope y'all
they already implemented elements of
scale bound into bayonetta into
bayonetta three with the giant kaiju
battles
okay okay we got that we got sage with
the five dollars
platinum the baby ain't mine raise that
kid yourself if the kid gonna make it to
the nba i'll pay the child support then
what i'm talking about he better be a
star
[Laughter]
how does a microsoft have at japanese
games rejected
i say get vanquish too exclusive or new
ip and see how the relationship is after
that
okay then we got hard get your knee five
dollars we chat xbox going to retire
call of duty 2025 we'll see the new
franchise duty calls
our toilet simulator duty calls
there we go
[Laughter]
then we got picks some veggies with chat
y'all want microsoft to read chill yeah
i want microsoft to re-raw the chick
that burnt them whoa
whoa
that's so extra right there
jesus jesus you took the time out to
type that in
sometimes i question like
the the amount of stuff that the view
it's like oh hold up they they will
change their names so yes
so solve will have to say
the super chat crazy stuff
this is pixel bit g this is the homie we
already know
continue
and we got splendiferous two dollars
that's like getting nice to spit on 50
cellos album
[Laughter]
okay all right hold on a second then we
have uh no hold on a second we got roll
back a little bit oh no taco
okay we read the platinum misses we've
read that one already
okay so after donald taco is
mr two opinionated five dollars super
chat
if microsoft got another japanese
exclusive scale bound wouldn't be
mentioned much he'll at least get
miles's phantom dust back
damn
hectic world 5 super chat all platinum
games are single player without
multiplayer that's why i failed to scale
bound just deal with it
yup i'm with you maybe this time yeah
don't don't force them to do something
they're not gonna do it they'll do that
and definitely don't but they do require
some supervision this time all right
we will not be monitoring them allow
them to go someplace
then we got donald taco again he's funny
he said finally we can get to the real
topic nintendo completely dominating
xbox and playstation with their
untouchable exclusive lineup that rivals
2017 i won't respect any nintendo
slander today king wow we got two it's a
combo topic for the last one hey
playstation nintendo um
i won't take it okay
oh record
yeah we're caught up all right let's get
into it so this two-part uh topic to set
up king
with his
couldn't wait to tell if i talk about
this in the realm
oh yeah so it looks like sony will be
beta testing hey playstation voice
commands for the ps5 saudi is also
making changes to the way parties work
so pretty much this was wednesday
according to the blog post your ps5 can
listen for the hey playstation voice
command to let you find and open games
apps and settings as well as control
playback during a show or song if you
don't want to use it sony says you can
turn the feature off and the voice
command features for beta test right now
sony is also making changes to party tat
party chats voice chats are now called
parties and you can now choose whether a
party is open meaning your friends can
join without an invitation or close so
king
you couldn't wait to talk about hey
playstation you know hold up before he
goes i was wondering i didn't research
this at all yeah because it's like voice
stuff and i'm sitting here wondering the
whole time you're reading why did he
pick this topic
that last couple sentences i'm like oh
so they ain't 20 20 now yeah you know
what it is i now i know what it is
right now we know what this is so king
venus is a hot topic for you and you
wanted to really bring this to the right
we're not going to talk about i don't
know we're talking about anything no the
censoring thing oh i didn't forgot about
that oh you saw any centering stuff
again
hey playstation
let's just combine all three that hey
let's start playstation first and then
after that we'll do the details we got
to talk about the intended record
everybody was clowning us with xbox on
xbox hey playstation refund oh my god
hey xbox can you rewind hey xbox record
that hey playstation
who are you like you you're forget yo
it's like jim is going through all xbox
albums and like oh that was a hit
yo hey places little a tracks
yo soon you're gonna have to [ __ ] with a
camera
[Music]
soon you're gonna put drm back in your
box
like it's you are literally living our
past all over again
how the hell are you gonna even look
them in the face and say hey playstation
i can't see it like that
hey king hey
hey playstation boo-boo
hey playstation snap
yo what's what's really happening i i
swear to god it feels like i'm in the
time loop because wasn't they clowning
xbox with the kinect and and and all the
xbox discs and xbox that and nobody
wanted that feature and nobody want the
xbox listening to him but lo and behold
your playstation they told you send them
their ears the playstation is listening
and it responds to hey playstation
i just want to know how y'all feel
with the hey yo why it gotta be
this is what happens this is what
happens when you
when you start a new generation and you
try to revamp everything right you start
you lose you lose stuff that you had as
the norm on the previous generation and
that's what's happened with playstation
when the playstation 5 came out the ui
was completely different and to to do
the things that you did simply on the
ps4 was cumbersome as a pain it was a
pain in the rear and so little by little
they just kind of kept are continuing to
reincorporate those things to simplify
that playstation 4 ui
um because on the playstation 5 there's
multiple button presses sometimes for
certain things that were very simple on
the ps4 so now it's this thing where
it's like you know they implemented
things that were just there before and
it's funny because when you think about
it now you know everybody talks to alexa
or whatever like but it's old it's old
tech it's old news and it's just the
fact that it's taking this long to
implement into this new ui is just funny
like it almost to the point you don't
need it but at the same time somebody
who uses is going to be like why the
hell is this old thing that used to be
there not there anymore so yeah i get it
it just whatever like i don't
my playstation 5 is to i get on i play
the games that's it all the other
features i don't really care about on
you so it doesn't affect me but it is
funny that you know this is almost two
going into two years of the the system
being out and we're still trying to get
there like it's it's just funny
thoughts hey playstation i mean when
when you see this it is funny it's
hilarious i ain't gonna lie like it is
but i don't think you really saw sony
clowning on the connect as much as the
fan base was clowning on the connect
so you know i think it's one of those
things where it's like
microsoft jumped the gun on that type of
technology keep in mind that they're
doing this as like like a side thing
it's like you know you got you put satan
to your mic like microsoft was forcing
features on you that's what because face
22 23 he all over me i didn't say he all
he he got smoking he's like this is not
forced on you king this is not the same
he covered that kick hard but
that's all like that's all
the thing is
the thing is i think this is a prime
example of just playstation
updating with the times because yeah and
it's an example of of microsoft being
ahead of the times and they got
ridiculed because they were too they
were thinking too far ahead
you saw you saw it with the al always
online thing oh i i don't want my games
to all only be online now probably 40 50
of the games are always online right so
that was again a scenario where
microsoft wasn't in the wrong for trying
it but they didn't do a good job
communicating about what it was about
and they didn't do a good job at showing
the people the positives to that
technology for instance this technology
wasn't huge back in 2013 but now it's a
lot more thing everyone got an echo
everyone got an alexa i think that might
be the same thing but it is what it is
and it's just like look with these type
of technologies getting really really
more advanced the casuals now know that
when you speak to an alexa they're going
to talk back and give you the
information that you want so playstation
wants to get in on that trend now right
um i'll jump in i literally care less
but yeah congrats hey hey playstation
yeah you know i don't know you don't say
like some people use the feature
whatever i agree it's it is not forced
um
look all i cared about was the party
chat thank god i did not like
that game base was important i hated
that so that was for me that was the
biggest part of this dude is you named
it party chat you made that interface
more cleaner and smaller let's go you
don't say i'm all about but i know king
where he saw hey playstation they're
breathing
what is he doing
yeah christopher says i read that
article when he posted on the chat i got
your controller like that what do you do
i see him all right
i read that article in the chat for like
15 seconds i was like i have no
interest in anything in this article
but the article about the hey
playstation thing but i will say that
the party system over there i don't know
if this update's done i i i haven't
turned bait it's in the beta right now
but it's just like
this needed to be done like sony was so
far behind on social features it's
unreal they still don't have gifting on
playstation right now yeah they need
gift cards yeah that sucks feature
is not only do you blow into it
you talk to it too
hey playstation
[Laughter]
you having a ball with this i can't
believe this is a topic moving on to the
real news that shout out to donald taco
you know what i'm saying we've been
waiting patiently we finally had a
switch topic it's been a minute you
oh sorry sensory yes please thoughts
before we move over into the bushes
suppose uh well it's not supposedly like
sony i didn't like look into it 100 but
they've been known in the past to like
to censor a lot of different type of
games but like apparently this is the
first one that really hit them hard like
because most of the time
it's some weirdo stuff we didn't really
want it on the platform anyway uh you
know we won't go too much into what it
was and stuff but this is the one time
where it's like maybe this is something
they shouldn't have done and i i
definitely i feel like
you know censoring is
i understand censoring if you don't
agree with it but they will be censoring
stuff that their own games do it makes
no sense yeah i i don't know enough
about it this stuff came across about
that desk late but for what i understand
you know the version for playstation is
going to be delayed or something like
that or the the physical release yeah
the physical release will be delayed
there's an edited version look y'all
know how i feel like i am not about
censorship i'm pro-death so i'm not
about censorship on any level so the
fact that that is happening is not a
good look i don't i don't i don't agree
with that so i don't know why they came
to that decision because apparently xbox
and the other platforms aren't getting
the un
edited
yes which is doing which is surprising
to me too so they might i don't know
but they've been in the past they've
done
uh stuff that playstation has censored
yeah so i don't understand where the
communication broke down there and why
that's happening so yeah it's a bad look
i see i i got a shout out to playstation
nation i see a lot of sony guys getting
on playstation but it's like yo this is
not a good look you know why you central
to me i always feel as a developer or
creator you should be allowed to create
what you want to create and then it's up
to us as the consumer whether we choose
to support that or the other you out of
pocket right yeah that's how i feel but
you know they got to deal with that it's
just it's not a good look so that's all
i could say over there i didn't really
do my research on it but king i don't
know if i got it yeah as long as you to
me as long as the game is labeled
properly for the right audience there
should be no reason to censor anything
right i'm reading right now on bgc what
it is that was that yeah what's the
concert and so okay so apparently
there's a scene in the dream sequence
where you like you slice someone's face
off and you put you put you put it on as
like a mask or something like that so
it's really like something
and then there's another part where your
sister is like in a casket and you have
to take pictures of their body in the
casket
so that's it like maybe there's
something else but it's like that to me
that doesn't make it it's so weird i
don't think there's more violence in the
last of us shout out to ksi they said
there's a part in the game where they
make you raise the blade off a face and
wear it that's what's being censored i
mean
if i think tony for protecting me
protecting the children that's what i
thought the esrb was for right this
didn't right and this is what we fought
for so i don't understand it so
hopefully the public pressure to get
them to change their stance because i
don't want to go in that direction okay
it's weird who would take a stance on
this this is very weird to me yeah very
strange well i i mean especially when i
feel like last week
outside yeah like last of us was outside
i i tr i trust sony and i and i trust
the choices that they're making for me
because you know sometimes i i don't
want razor blades on the face and i
really think that sony is doing the
right thing here guys i think this is
why we get like whatever this is why we
gotta leave it
i think they're looking out for our best
interest because sony knows best hey
sony
playstation
what's up bro i know you happy right now
we get a chance to talk about it
what about this direct let's start with
attic man real quick though oh wait that
makes it a little different the face
pill scene was a kid
oh
i mean again
again
i mean i'm not trying to but there's
always been like this this undo law in
gaming where you don't mess with the
kids like even elder scrolls you can't
kill kids in like almost all the games i
mean we came from fable we people stack
kids up in the temples
you came from bully like again we got to
be careful with this slippery slope
this is the game we fought for mortal
kombat i remember mortal kombat was not
a goal they were trying to we got to be
careful let them create just put the
ratings and say hey child violence and
apparently in the uh what i did read the
developer put in the things he said the
face pill was not a kid i don't know
what's going on well whatever is going
on at the end of the day
the end of the day the developer thing
that i did see say that they were very
specific in what type of graphical
violence content they put up i heard
they put warnings in the game but hey if
you are uncomfortable with blah blah
blah this is not the game for you so as
long as you take those precautions i
don't see what the issue is that's just
me i come from that you know what i'm
saying so anyway continue yeah um
yeah let's get super chat real quick
before we just move on uh dd lee member
for 21 this was an eye opening and
illuminating episode of iop
with an eye
sonia is trying to take the pole dancer
out the club knowing she likes to see
them bands
then we got mr irishman bypassing which
on fact banner the three lead game
designer started working for tango
gameworks last month
then we have cmad five dollars if you
check if you're a sony what's your offer
slash slash pitch to microsoft for the
game properties less having to accept
game pass go
pay playstation
[Laughter]
yo
continue
my
my my pitch would be if you don't do
what we're gonna say we're gonna bite if
it's
how did you how are you gonna threaten
ownership over your company
i'll i'll tip for chatting i'd be like
oh you know what you know what king said
my crib was robbed last night it's been
so stressful but i'm blessed that my fam
is safe and i'm alive watching my
favorite podcast live iop glad to hear
you're safe that's a horrible thing i'm
sorry brother invasion of your your
space and your property personally yeah
yeah that's that's something that's hard
to give any comfort during a tough time
happy and thankful to do that brother
but thank you already
glad to hear you guys that you were okay
and no one lost their life that's the
main thing yeah
then we have donald taco again
i don't know a second he's got scroll
back the face pill thing was a kid and
that's what they're freaking out about
but i still don't think that's enough to
censor i
they don't why would they not say that
in the article though and we have emery
five dollar super chat amazon brought
out alexa devices in 2013. same year as
connect and xbox one gamers are late
with tech for two chances
it's new stuff what are you talking
about this is new hey playstation is new
then we got lord metro
two dollar super chat there we go lord
metro speaking of sponsor early fans
was short as whack
yeah yeah like the whole nintendo topic
that's coming up next
scary score was a good game i enjoyed it
yeah i don't listen to him he mad he mad
cause metroid sits outside
well i i literally just agreed with you
like no i'm talking about you
right you're talking about lord betrayed
you okay he's mad that metroid sits
outside where it belongs
but in the bushes we're done let's go
cod can't hear you
sorry nintendo direct let's let's talk
about it who saw it what's going on at
it you was kind of hype outdoor i was
shocked
it was it was a good direct like it was
a really solid direct
um you know it showed me some things i
want to play with on my switch but i've
said multiple times over and over again
you know with
third-party stuff not really hugely
present and if it is present i'd rather
play it on a better performing platform
their first part is the only stuff i
care about and they still lack it
but i do feel like they did give the
switch user base reasons to play the
switch this year
maybe not always me
because i i want to play that uh i'm
going to review that
that final fantasy tactics game uh it's
not it's not actually final fantasy
practice but it's inspired it's like
strategy triangle strategy yeah so i
think that's a really good solid
experience i'll have for them i'm gonna
uh review that on the iron lord's
podcast channel so definitely look out
for that but as far besides that like i
don't really see
like anything
like to the scales of like horizon on
their platform this year so far or you
know the to the scales of
even star field like it's just i feel
like mario strikers
yeah that's cool but can we really
compare that to games like like i don't
like unless breath of the wild doesn't
come out this year it comes out this
year i don't see
like one of their games being in that
game of the year talk so i don't think
that's not coming in
i think we're getting those
announcements in june that's what i
think yeah but usually when the june
stuff happens that's for the year after
no not really second half
okay they'll give you some stuff for the
beginning i'd be right you know i
i might not entirely pay attention
you might not have entirely absorbed the
information correctly
shout out to you not doing the research
salute to you
i like attention but that's all man
as far as reading i was elected to do a
podcast not to read i have done with you
moving on that's off the simpsons in
case you don't know
i gotta break protocol real quick
because we lost mexican zoey where five
dollars with chat playstation hey king
boo boo king hey playstation
you stupid shout out to mexico everybody
saw
what's coming in hot for you with this
direction no they they really are like
friends
in terms of their first party stuff
let's get it they're finally showing
love to like the the bt or the c tears
and stuff you haven't seen for a long
time obviously advanced war is finally
coming back yeah that kirby looked good
kirby's perfect
but it looked like something i could see
the user base playing and i it looked
like something that was quality but it
seems it wasn't
right it seemed closer kofi's calling
that kirby odyssey
odyssey yeah no because it it really
does feel like that and but kirby curry
games are mostly for children and this
may be like just as easy but at least
that it seems like it'll be more widely
appealing to the rest of the swiss crowd
um but splatoon 3
like uh
little things that they showed like that
um what the heck else so we have chrono
cross we have kirby we have the the
clonoa series that play up playstation
doesn't seem to care about the legacy
but but obviously
certain games that were on the
playstation are coming to the uh to the
switch
um triangle strategy like attic said
those are the perfect types of games for
the for the switch
um
the stuff they're doing with mario kart
8. yeah talk about it kind of crazy this
is what i was talking about like they
essentially turned this game into a
service it's the game service
it really is never getting married
dude
48 brand 48 jacks tracks
yeah essentially and they're going to
give that to if you already have that
that online stuff it's already included
otherwise it's 25
yeah even even if it's not included you
don't have that online stuff it's 25
bucks for 48 new tracks over the course
they kind of slick with the locker you
get to expect the online pass but you
want to get in that all-out pass
expansion
we have to give them a lot of props
because we really attacked that n64
expansion and uh
[Music]
but now i see a little bit more of their
overall view of they want to do it like
that's kind of like their ultimate it
just feels like all of their dlc is
going to go in there right any any
significant and i just think that gives
it value absolutely absolutely again if
you if you weren't an animal crossing
person that first that upgrade didn't
mean much to you this
this we talked about it last week man
that mario kart is the goat it just
keeps selling um when the next pokemon
comes out and the expansions come up
arceus is going crazy too
um
it just feels like the switch is finally
doing
even on the third party side what it was
meant to do which is i remember saying
so i just want all of my old games on
there and they're getting there now the
problem is
they're doing that you've got the portal
you've got all this stuff assassin's
creed the problem is that now we've
elevate see back then we were all cool
still with 30 fps
anymore like
yeah we're gonna need a new switch to to
have that be viable let me
feel it that no man's sky moving away
was moving
that's fine no what i wasn't feeling
that
the fact that the show was hiccuping
during the stream i was like you saw
that
i was like oh no
yeah yeah
but again i i think
they're they're being good at what
they're good at they're still gonna be
bad at what they're bad at because
they're not making any they're not
making any headway there
they they need a new machine if they're
going to be talking about these games
that are coming out now otherwise
but that's the thing that's the thing if
they if they they already said it's like
all your stuff you guys doing sony
playstation and xbox buying all this
we're not about that we're good where we
are
they're going to be good where they are
until
i will say this
if one of the big two
takes a japanese publisher off the table
then you got to start thinking a little
bit differently then you cannot be in
this wall garden by yourself and not pay
attention to what's going on because
nintendo you can affect it
i mean i think it was i honestly feel
like if nintendo wanted to
they could live without third party
support like they kind of got the amp up
stuff kind of been doing it but they do
but they don't because they still get a
lot of support from third party studios
as timed exclusives
i mean like second party second party
sort of yeah third party exclusive yeah
right that sort of stuff is going to be
off the table and you know carl didn't
know that octopath travel is not on
playstation i didn't know that no yeah
it's only on xbox and switch and pc it
was weird that it came to xbox with the
game passed up so to me
i think this is for what switch is and
is becoming and transforming into it's
it's great
i think they're going to continue to
focus on their ip the way they always
have i think when we look at this and
then we look at what i assume they're
going to talk about in june
it could be 2017 all over again
and bro by the end of the year we could
be looking at we could be looking at 130
million plus
wow
so i don't care i don't care how the
game's running
don't get mad don't get mad don't get
back
it's just the truth now
all i'm saying is
i'm happy that we had an eye doctor on
the show
yo don't you
[Music]
you watch this thing
you know what makes me mad about it i'm
not doing research yeah because you know
because king king is always talking
about oh i played i played the nintendo
games though even fraud on the nintendo
game no no no let me know
let me be honest with you there was a
lot of stuff that was going on uh this
week and they said that the nintendo
direct was up and when i went to go
watch it i did get a chance to watch it
and then i saw a spawn wave and spawn
wave looked like he was really pissed
off
he was yo that xbox direct was crazy
so if if 90 of those games is coming to
xbox and you got like uh ten percent
that's not a lot what's coming here yeah
this is what i'm saying like i'd rather
play them in good resolution that after
me
shout over happy birthday but that's
what i don't know in the day
but he i mean he had plenty for him too
like
nintendo i say god bless i got game pass
like you really want i'm a oh i'm gonna
buy that nintendo with a service thing
but what what if they put gay pass on
switch would it would it then get you
back yeah it would make waves over here
but it's all they didn't date
here we go again
it's more like mario like rugby like
like wrestling oh just because you want
to turn it to rugby now i'm supposed to
be amp
out here
and messing up over i don't care about
none of that stuff that you talked about
but you played less than a real game you
played plenty of lesser quality games in
game pads yes
you know what's crazy yeah the pocket i
don't
know
i know i know so ask me this am i
running out spending 56.95 for strikers
56.95 look man all i know
is i don't know if i'll be playing mario
strikers because that those type of
games don't normally interest me i might
buy it if like enough of my uh like i
have a friend uh evan we play like uh
mario party but like when it comes to
strikers
i'll probably play it if other people
play yeah nothing
i've always been one of those people
it doesn't matter if it's not in game
pass if it doesn't matter if it's in
playstation now even if it's on stadium
interests me enough i'm going there
let's go for it
yo this is a strong one this is a strong
one they came out i didn't expect
nothing from this one they had some
joints not everything was for me but i
think they had a little bit for everyone
yeah correct yeah they had a strolling
in in a time that really i didn't think
they had a lot to talk about but um for
me the advanced wars look fire um
force unleashed can we talk about that
like advanced events is 60
i gotta agree with him on that man that
game does not look like a 60 dollar game
uh
this is where my fourth nerve poses come
into play
you gotta hold one eye when you
switch it this is what they said it's
the problem with the gamers the xbox
guys they didn't want to buy games they
just want to wait for services
i have no problem buying games but i do
value certain games over others i can
show you right now advanced warfare for
sixty dollars is not the value that i'm
looking for now i will say i would wait
for uh for some type of some type of
savings with the nintendo switch but we
know they don't do that either so i'm
probably not gonna be buying that game
tell the truth but it looks fun it does
look fun
tell them anyway
and did do people see how that how force
unleashed in the assassin's creed
collection look like yeah
they were literally one step above lego
games like that's how bad they were
this is crazy
look the the force unleashed for
whatever reason
they ported the wii version yeah i don't
understand that that's true they did
what they could do
now
we're not gonna front like the switches
are more powerful than the 360. those
games ran on the 360. so right for
whatever reason again it's we're not you
30 fps is out the window we don't need
that no more that's because when it
comes to third party they do whatever
they can to get the game working on the
system and then they're like we don't
care about anything besides that it runs
right start menu you can press a ship it
services
anyway shout out to steph gilbert what's
going on um they know they demographic
look
i thought mlb the show
that was a good good look for them they
had that promotion oh no i had a feeling
yeah i had a feeling it was gonna they
were gonna show game cross play cross
progression
even if it's two frames a second they
get my money you can continue your
season on the go you don't see it then i
try to play that you gear game on switch
it was it was bad so i don't like the
video game on the switch anymore i will
say this you know to me the one that
people sleeping on though that there was
they brought the was they called it
switch sports down the wii sports
with the new just listen people can say
what they want king we just had that we
had that xbox one uh retrospective on
ddu we talked about the connect and we
all know to connect did bite off of the
wii's
flow right so and that was the packing
game that
volleyball bowling tennis yeah but
that's gonna move
i think people are going to buy it and
it's going to do well but i don't think
it has any
i don't think it has any chance of
reclaiming what it done in the past no i
think unless they consider it a packing
no
they might right they might make that a
packet when i saw that i was thinking
that would be a great packing switch
game
switch light owners can they play
switchboards partake
like because i know what they said you
can use one joy-con to play the joy so
i'm because what the motion the problems
they'll probably make versions of that
that go for the light too you see people
out there swinging these switches
anyway i mean you see you know you have
people breaking because they threw their
switch and they like i didn't get the
memo
they put a wrist strap on the switch
i think what you can do right you could
do you could you could connect another
set of joy cons to it and if you prop it
up somewhere and play it that way
that's it
but you're not playing it yeah i mean
they basically basically anyway
literally had enough of this time all to
say the last thing i did think from a
fan standpoint they ended the show well
xeno uh what is it um
three you know saying major franchise
for them then they had they they had the
fire emblem three warriors
yeah
it was a good show it was a goal one of
the best things
everybody's telling me it's a good job
yeah super strong show they they showed
up they really it appeared i didn't
think they were gonna have a lot to talk
about it was a super strong show they
rock it and um
still my greatest draft pick the
nintendo switch which i told people who
laughed at me who said this generation
who's gonna buy it who was gonna who's
this for all is i told y'all this was
going to be that one this is my greatest
draft i have sold nintendo with this
cause no everyone laughed me out the
room and i said there's going to be a
market for this trust me when i say it
and they got the third party support
they killed it and um people acting like
they that winning generation every every
month for the most part right you know
so what do you mean a free eye doctor
visit
switch coming in hot y'all i don't i
think that the only people that really
question if the switch is gonna be
success
was the people that don't have an idea
of how popular they're on the mobile
division like once i saw they hybrided
them i already knew it was going to be
successful because because they've not
made nothing that's mobile that's not
been gold
shout out to earthbound that was the
last one but that's it let's get up
youtube check it about here i'll read
the uh the poll while you are what you
call it waiting if you want yourself
down i'm ready are you ready let's do it
yeah there wasn't a whole lot leading
into it um
we have donald taco two dollars
september directors for the year after
so yeah so the june direct is still for
this year's september directors were for
it's coming the following year okay and
we got target chinese five dollars super
chat nintendo games will outsell the
playstation games nintendo ahead
dominating but playstation xbox players
don't want to acknowledge talk talk talk
talk go dominate
that's one of the reasons you don't see
like playstation fanboys bringing up
like cells anymore because there's no
reason to bring that up
you can't go on there and bring up that
you got second oh
you can't read it anyway
not ridiculous
then we got flame two dollar super chat
shout out to curry and the throat mobile
whoa
whoa
if you don't know what he's talking
about watch that watch he'll watch that
trailer yeah
um then we have no the taco 5
20 22 is the send-off of this gen that's
why they're going hard 2023 will be
quiet and then 2024 the next gen switch
will come out and dominate
oh man look at that i don't think it's a
send off quite yet though i know i've
been talking about that switch pro for
the last five years
that is kind of true and they gave you a
old lead
yo
savage
and we got hectic world five dollar
super chat
the new switches the steam deck no
waiting on nintendo just emulate people
like i will but first party only yeah
thank you for telling us of the robbery
you're about to be started doing it
that's great you're right you know one
more podcast we don't uh the fdc is
watching
you know what it is easy don't let the
feces get you pause
you ready to go
listen i will say this
yes i know what he's saying
the steam deck at the 400 price point it
could but if you can't get enough of
those into people's hands it doesn't
matter we've already shown that it's not
just this type of the most powerful
thing does not guarantee you generation
that's right
then we got necromancer zell five
dollars which it's time for the switch
too i can't stand the downgraded
gameplay on this ancient console
you won't see there we go we're coming
there we got otaku 5 super chat king
talking about switzer's performance but
they had more first party 60 fps games
than ps4 and xbox one
and you didn't see them shout out to the
cat the cataract corrections
uh then donald taco again two dollars
which had the force and lease was a port
of the wii version like i said yeah
i don't know what the hell was that
about i don't know what they were that
about it's lit
that we got you know it's me
then we got haruki chinese five dollar
super chat man and nintendo comes out
with breath of the wild two in the fall
and announced the next mario game for
spring
damn game over
oh my god
it's lit
i've got time taiwaki
you're there
xbox could never do it with mostly first
party they're in a lane of their own
that is that all right let me read the
um actually the merch real quick and
then the paul would get out of here
shout out to the stuff shawn got that
classic t got that phil dominance salute
to the lord from the emerald realm of
ireland thank you for this amazing show
every week shout out to the best team in
new york he said go bills wow
phil okay then we got home too
kate johnson for the ladies he got that
phil dominance for the lady picked it up
for the lady to go around okay he had to
scoop his shirt and support the he said
the i l p e y e l
oh sorry okay yeah she brought the
woman's cup oh hello to the lady in the
realm she got okay she had to put the
eye out
salute thank you sorry about that and
then um yeah let's get the poll let's
get this cleaned up with microsoft
recently stating that they will continue
to make call of duty and other popular
activision blizzard titles available on
playstation what other popular
activision blizzard game do you think
will remain multi-platform choices are a
overwatch 2
b
diablo 4
c
both
or d
i don't care we all know the feds is
parked outside redmond campus right now
salute to all the people in the vote
going on you already know so salute it
was a fantastic i guess the doctor i got
pulling up absolutely hilarious oh shout
out to donald taco upgraded his
membership salute to you but yeah we had
a good one more fun hopefully a big
surprise this month i don't want to jinx
it but attic knows we're trying to work
on something real special we got things
cooking up but uh at it where can i find
people find you what you got going on
sir
for me on twitter lord addicts iop you
can find me on youtube gaming act i'll
be releasing a video tomorrow uh also we
will
uh keep an eye on the memberships and
the uh
in the patreon we'll be go ahead and
doing another uh lord's play community
night i don't know when it's going to be
i don't know what game it's going to be
but we're going to what we're going to
do is i'm going to put up
i'm going to put up a post on both and
you're going to put games in there and
we're going to put pick four games that
you guys put in both of those so we're
picking the four games that you guys put
in there and then we'll put those on
twitter and let everyone choose but the
members and patreons will be the one
picking the game that we play no doubt
no doubt
lord solve look at the five people find
you what you got going on sir
nothing nothing i did i'm trying to play
more seafood man just trying to get
better at that game it's a great game i
wish if we didn't have a guest i would
have talked about it more yeah he's a
great guy next week we'll talk about
seafood a little bit more in depth but
like yo
the only issue i'm really having with it
is the camera gets stupid sometimes but
apart from that like i don't mind it
kicking my ass it is really really
really
really a good game i loved it
that's it no doubt lord king
we're gonna find people finding what you
got going on explaining the rules of uh
knee bending
there's a lot of stuff that's weird with
these guys and i just sit there and
watch these grown uh strong babies cry i
think a lot of them
they're not even really saying like you
have to like they know that the betting
thing going on but it's just like a
community thing that they like throwing
back at you where's the knees
like
they've lost so much that they're
grasping oh my gosh oh my god
let's not open it up
i've seen generals arise from the grave
i guess i'm calling them generals now
yeah well they're not they're generally
gone or you just called them generals
spoke they used to be time gets back
together until i had to lay waste to the
whole nation
but i do have fun with these guys on
twitter and i love engaging somebody
said oh i you know i follow a lot of
people because i'm not an elitist i
don't care my follower is not
conditional on something else it's just
whatever you follow me i follow you and
if you're respectful we have uh fun
topics that we can talk about and engage
throughout the day and hopefully we can
put smiles on each other faces because
at the end of the day we all play games
yeah i joke around but if breath of the
wild two come out this year i'll be at
the store did he be getting my money and
i'll be going to get cataract correction
surgery later
but at the end of the day is about these
games and i love just to say
hey playstations
that's what this is all about hey you
got to say you got to say with the blaze
4k works
yo
baby
i can't
okay he is really entertaining about
that feature anyway again shout out
shout out to the chat shout out to
everybody shout out alex everybody else
pulled up to be silly um yo we got some
fun stuff lined up this month again
trying to do something really special
and big um stay tuned for that we'll
hopefully try to make something happen
and uh yeah that's all i got addictor we
good
yeah we're good and again thank y'all
for dealing with the technical
difficulties we have figured it out and
hopefully it's not again anytime soon
i'll catch up everybody enjoy the super
bowl
do your thing
we're gonna help
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you